Bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce qui sera je l'espère notre saga de l'été.
Il s'agit de cours de paléo-mammalogie. Il s'agit des cours de paléo-mammalogie que je donne ici, en Afrique du Sud, niveau master
et vous avez été nombreux à me demander de mettre en ligne des cours comme j'avais fait pour les cétacés et bien voilà !
j'espère que ce sera notre fil rouge de l'été : une vidéo par semaine,
un cours de paléo-mammalogie par semaine et on commence du coup aujourd'hui
avec un petit aperçu général
d'une part de la diversité des mammifères au mésozoïque, mais surtout de la phylogénie des mammifères.
comme ça on évacue la phylogénie dès le premier cours et on a pu aller revenir dessus
mais vous verrez que la phylogénie en elle-même c'est un très très gros morceau.
Donc sans plus attendre, commençons avec la paléo-mammalogie.
Alors comme il s'agit des cours que je donne en Afrique du Sud
vous allez voir que, d'une part c'est tout en anglais mais bon, au moins ça donne un petit côté international.
Voilà on est comme ça, on est généreux avec le langage
Et surtout, vous allez voir que c'est très africano-centré,
c'est à dire que je montre surtout des fossiles qui sont trouvés en Afrique
Pourquoi ? pour la simple raison que si vous regardez les livres de cours ils sont tous écrits par des américains ou des anglais
à ma connaissance il y en a pas qui était écrit récemment en français
mais voilà ils sont tous écrits par des américains ou des anglais
et donc c'est que des exemples qui viennent ou d'europe ou d'amérique ou d'asie
et très très peu qui viennent d'Afrique donc du coup là, c'est très africao-centré, histoire finalement, de donner à mes étudiants
la capacité de voir ce qui se fait sur leur continent
sachant que la capacité de voir ce qui se passe ailleurs ils l'auront dans n'importe quel bouquin, en gros.
Mais je vais vous donner les exemples équivalent en Europe
et je vais essayer de trouver notamment des exemples qui touche à la France
et qui sont équivalents à ce que je montre ici.
Donc là par exemple, on va commencer par les mammifères mésozoïques
Ce qu'on doit appeler normalement les "mammaliaformes mésozoïques" parce que
finalement ce qu'on appelle les mammifères du clade Mammalia,
c'est l'ancêtre commun des monotrèmes, des marsupiaux et des placentaires et tous les descendants de cet ancêtre commun.
Et il se trouve que les choses qu'on appelle les mammifères au mésozoïque ne sont pas forcément descendants de cet ancêtre commun
et c'est pour ça qu'on les appelle des mammaliaformes et pas des Mammalia, donc pas des vrais mammifères,
ce sont des mammiféromorphes.
Mais ce ne sont déjà plus des cynodontes,
c'est à dire les ancêtres des mammifères. Mais ça, ça fera l'objet d'un autre cours.
On les fera sur la fin les cynodontes juste pour rappeler ce que c'est que l'origine finalement des mammifères.
Donc là, ce que vous voyez à l'écran et bien ce sont les mammaliaformes du mésozoïque.
Donc les mammaliaformes du mésozoïque, typiquement ce sont des animaux qui ressemble à des musaraignes.
Pas à des rongeurs. Par pitié ne dites plus qu'ils ressemblent à des rongeurs :
les rongeurs sont des herbivores ultraspécialisés.
Les mammifères ressemblaient à des musaraignes.
Ils ressemblaient à des musaraignes parce qu'ils étaient tous insectivores
globalement nocturnes ou presque tous nocturnes, d'où la baisse au niveau de l'acuité visuelle
la plupart des mammifères ont hérité de cet ancêtre nocturne,
la perte de deux cônes sur les quatre qu'avaient les ancêtres des amniotes
donc la perte de la vision des couleurs au final et la plupart des mammifères ne voit pas les couleurs
à part l'exemple des primates
dont nous sommes fièrement représentants.
Donc voilà : ancêtres nocturnes,
insectivores donc avec des dents très pointue très comique
mais avec des molaires complexe (ce qui les distingue de leurs ancêtres les cynodontes)
un cerveau globalement plus gros que ceux des cynodontes.
Donc ici, vous voyez, c'est le cerveau de Megazostrodon qui est cet animal que vous voyez là.
Vous voyez que les hémisphères cérébraux sont bien développés comparer un cynodonte
qui a un cerveau tubulaire qui est très très semblable à celui des reptiles.
Et surtout, et bien ils avaient très probablement la capacité de pondre des œufs.
Les marsupiaux et les placentaire ne pondent pas d’œuf mais les monotrèmes
(donc l'ornithorynque et les échidnés)
pondent des œufs, donc par extension les mammaliaformes qui sont plus primitifs que ces mammifères
de ce point de vue là devaient pondre des œufs.
Donc quand on vous dit que le marsupilami est un monotrème parce qu'il ponds des œufs, c'est pas vrai !
Il y a beaucoup de mammaliaformes qui pondent des œufs, très probablement la quasi entièreté des mammaliaformes du mésozoïque.
Et donc, qu'est ce que ces mammifères mésozoïques, ces mammaliaformes mésozoïque ont en commun avec les cynodontes ?
Et bien ce sont les choses que tous les synapsides ont en commun.
À savoir : la fosse temporal et la distinction de la dentition.
Donc ici vous voyez il y a une canine dans la dentition qui sépare des incisives
de prémolaires et de molaires et ça c'est propre à tous les synapsides.
Donc ce qui fait des mammaliaformes mésozoïques mais aussi des mammifères modernes
des membres du clade des synapsides, mais comme je l'ai dit nous verrons tout cela dans une prochaine vidéo.
Alors l'évolution depuis les synapsides ancestraux jusqu'au mammaliaformes
se caractérise par de nombreuses tendances évolutives
et il y a notamment une simplification général du crâne. Donc ça, c'est un crâne de mammifères typique,
ça c'est un crâne d'amniote basal typiques donc d'un synapside par exemple.
Et donc vous voyez que toute la région autour de l'orbite
a été simplifié à seulement trois os qui sont le frontal le lacrymal et le jugal.
et avec une participation du squamosal chez les mammifères pour faire le tour de l'orbite, complètement
et on a une perte aussi du quadratojugal
et une perte de la série qu'on appelle post-périétale,
donc c'est à l'arrière de l'os pariétal vous voyez la perte de ces trois os ici que sont
le supra temporal, le tabulaire, le post-pariétal.
Donc le crâne des mammifères est plus simple que celui de leurs ancêtres synapsides.
Donc quand on vous dit que l'évolution forme des individus complexes
voilà, un contre exemple magnifique !
Bon ça rend pas le crâne des mammifères si simple que ça pour autant
et voici donc la mosaïque des os que vous trouvez à l'intérieur des mammifères. donc ça c'est juste pour information évidemment
Donc ça c'est juste pour information. Évidemment...
Les informations qu'il y a sur cette image ne sont pas capitales pour comprendre
l'évolution des mammifères heureusement ! Mais...
si jamais vous êtes un peu perdu niveau ostéologie, voilà, vous pouvez toujours vous référer à ce moment-là de la présentation.
C'est au cas où c'est un peu la galère pour vous rappeler du nom de tous ses os.
Alors il y a une idée préconçue
et une idée que je véhicule moi même, évidemment parce que c'est tellement simple et facile à véhiculer.
C'est que les mammifères, les mammaliaformes du mésozoïque vivaient à l'ombre des dinosaures,
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure c'était typiquement des petit insectivores nocturnes
qui ont attendu là, sagement, dans un coin que les dinosaures crèvent pour pouvoir prendre leur place au cénozoïque.
C'est vrai dans les grandes lignes, mais on va voir que
justement les prochaines slides sont dédiés justement à la diversité des mammaliaformes mésozoïques
Pour montrer que c'est pas si simple que ça en réalité. C'est vrai dans les grandes lignes, ça l'est moins dans le détail.
Et notamment vous pouvez voir à travers cette phylogénie donc,
tout à l'heure on a vu Megazostrodon qui fait partie de la famille des Morganucodontidæ.
Du Morganucodon qu'on trouve en Angleterre, donc c'est pas très loin de chez nous
et il n'est pas complètement impossible qu'on trouve un Morganucodon en France un jour,
notamment dans l'est on a de très beaux mammifères du mésozoïque dans l'est de la France.
À Saint-Laurent de port si je me rappelle bien.
[edit : Saint-Nicolas de Port]
Donc on a du mammaliaforme en France,
et il n'est pas impossible qu'un jour on trouve du Morganucodon ou du Morganucodontidæ.
Mais vous voyez qu'il n'ya pas que les Morganucodontidæ,
il y a aussi des docodontes, des Australosphenidæ, des eutriconodontes,
des multituberculées qui passent même la limite crétacé-tertiaire et perdure jusqu'à l'oligocène,
ce sont des mammifères qui ressemblaient à des rongeurs et qui ont fini par être remplacés
par les vrais rongeurs pendant le cénozoïque. Vous avez les Spalacotheriidae...
Bon. bref. Vous avez tous ces noms et au final quand vous analysez bien :
les Australosphenidæ, ils ont donné les monotrèmes et vous avez les Boreosphenida donc ce clade là,
qui a survécu grâce aux métathériens qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les marsupiaux et les euthériens dont les survivants sont les placentaires.
Donc en fait, aujourd'hui on a trois grand clades de mammifères, ces trois grands clades là, alors que mésozoïque il y avait :
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 et 9 et 10 parce que les euthériens et les métathériens étaient déjà là
au mésozoïque, au moins au crétacé. Donc au crétacé on a quand même : 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 familles
de mammifères, enfin de mammaliaformes
Donc la diversité des mammifères en fait, aujourd'hui,
elle est réduite par rapport à celle qu'on avait au mésozoïque, donc déjà c'est un premier point.
Et ça a été très bien démontré par des articles récents, c'est que, en fait,
aujourd'hui on a une diversité en termes de famille qui est réduite par rapport à...
enfin en termes de super-ordre pardon (parce qu'on va pas appeler tout des familles),
en termes de super-ordre, on a une diversité qui est réduite de mammifères.
Et ça, je trouve que c'est quand même cool quoi de dire :
"Bah non, en fait au mésozoïque nos ancêtres, ils poutraient quoi ! ils poutraient dans le petit, mais ils poutraient !"
Voila.
Et vous voyez là la diversité des dents
qu'avaient les mammifères à l'époque des dents de type symmétrodonte, docodonte, triconodonte, multituberculée.
Aujourd'hui il n'y a plus que des dents de type tribosphénique.
On va voir tout à l'heure ce que ça veut dire,
mais aujourd'hui il n'y a plus qu'un seul type de dents chez les mammifères, c'est les dents tribosphéniques.
Alors qu'avant, il y avait tout ça.
Voilà
Donc, je vais vous montrer quelques exemples de petits mammaliaformes du mésozoïque, juste histoire qu'on s'amuse un peu,
donc là vous avez par exemple Castorocauda
qui est un mammifère donc du mésozoïque qui vivait au temps des dinosaures mais qui est amphibien.
Amphibien et comment on le sait ? enfin amphibie par amphibien,
qui est amphibie semi aquatique.
Comment on le sait ? quand on regarde le fossile on voit que sa queue a des vertèbres aplaties latéralement
comme celles d'un castor et y a même la préservation des tissus mous autour
qui montre que il avait la queue plate comme celle d'un castor,
donc Castorocauda était finalement l'équivalent d'un castor de l'époque.
Excepté qu'il était piscivore et non pas herbivore comme le sont les castors.
Et Castorocauda, il a aussi cette particularité, c'est qu'il vient de la fin du jurassique
et qu'il a des poils bien préservés sur le fossile et ça ça fait de lui la première
apparition des poils dans le registre fossile des mammifères, avant ça on n'a pas de poils dans le registre fossile des mammifères
Donc c'est plutôt cool
Castorocauda, il montre bien, voilà,
La diversité que pouvaient avoir les mammifères à l'époque.
Et en Afrique, il y a cet exemple de Ichtyoconodon qui était un mammifère,
un mammaliaforme du mésozoïque
avec des dents qui ressemble à celle d'un requin finalement,
d'où son nom : Ichtyoconodon, donc des dents coniques de poissons.
Évidemment, le célèbre Repenomanus du crétacé de chine, à l'intérieur duquel des petits os ont été trouvés
et pas n'importe lesquels, il s'agit des os d'un bébé dinosaure, donc c'était un animal
de la taille de la taille d'un chien
et qui bouffait du bébé dinosaure et ça c'est quand même plutôt cool
et ça montre que les mammifères étaient effectivement pas que
des petits insectivores nocturnes.
Et en Afrique, il y a un exemple en Angola de très très grosses,
enfin très très grosse pour l'époque évidemment, mais voilà une empreinte de 3 cm qui appartient à un mammifère
cette petite empreinte de pas elle est déjà plus grosse que tout le corps du Megazostrodon que je vous ai montré,
donc encore une fois on n'est pas sur du petit mammifère là.
Maiopatagium de la famille des Haramiyida est un mammifère
qui a finalement une membrane, donc un patagium, c'est de là que vient son nom,
Maiopatagium : la mère au patagium.
et qui est très très bien préservé. On voit ici, il n'y a pas vraiment de doute,
la préservation des tissus mous montre clairement que c'est pas une invention, il y avait bien un patagium tendu
entre les bras mais aussi entre les jambes de cet animal qui le faisait ressembler à un écureuil volant.
Mais, aucun rapport avec les écureuils volants : il s'agit d'un Haramiyida, donc un très proche parent finalement
de Megazostrodon qu'on a vu tout à l'heure et des morganucodontidés.
Les multituberculés dont je parlais tout à l'heure qui ressemblaient à des rongeurs donc
voilà, ils tiennent leur nom d'un des multiples tubercules de leurs dents comme vous pouvez voir ici.
Des multituberculés, on en trouve partout dans le monde ils ont un énorme succès évolutif.
Alors celui là, il est marrant parce qu'il vient des Carpates et il a les dents rouges. Donc il fait vraiment penser à un vampire.
Les dents ont été préservés comme ça, avec du rouge dessus. Bon, c'est quelque chose qu'on trouve encore aujourd'hui chez musaraignes par exemple.
il y a certaines musaraignes qui ont les dents rouges parce qu'elles sont enrichis en fer.
Et alors lui en plus, il a cette espèce de tronçonneuse
sur les prémolaires inférieures. C'est ce qu'on appelle une dent plagiolacoïde.
Donc c'est une des prémolaires en fait qui se transforme en...
je sais pas... on dirait une scie circulaire quoi. Elle bouge pas évidemment. Ce n'est pas une vraie scie circulaire, Mais voilà !
Et là on est sur de l'herbivore ultra-spécialisé avec les multituberculés
Encore un autre herbivore ultra spécialisés,
mais contrairement au multituberculés, vous pouvez voir qu'il était d'assez grande taille.
De la taille d'un bon gros castor aussi, comme tout à l'heure
et il s'agit de Vintana. Et alors ce qu'il ya d'intéressant avec Vintana, c'est qu'il a été trouvé à Madagascar,
donc c'est un représentant d'une faune assez différente du reste finalement.
Mais il a ces grosses dents de rongeurs, donc qu'il a l'allure général d'un castor il a des grosses dents de rougeurs
et il a cette espèce de truc là en dessous de l'arcade zygomatique.
donc ici vous avez l’œil et là vous avez l'arcade zygomatique qui a cette espèce de processus qui s'étend vers le bas
et quand on voit l'intérieur en fait, on voit que c'est une grosse zone d'insertion pour le muscle masseter donc
C'est la joue en fait c'est le muscle qui forme la joue et donc
cet animal avait une puissance de mastication dans les joues qui était ahurissante.
et on voit aussi une très très grande crête sagittale pour l'insertion du muscle temporal donc, très forte puissance masticatrice.
les dents sont à croissance continue, les molaires sont en croissance continue
et avec une surface très très plate et complètement érodée, donc on est vraiment sur un mammifère
qui imite complètement le mode de vie des rongeurs.
Mais encore une fois ce n'est pas un rongeur
Mais, toute cette magnifique diversité de mammifères mésozoïques
au bout d'un moment elle va rencontrer la très glorieuse et mortelle
limite crétacé-tertiaire, la limite crétacé-paléogène comme on l'appelle des fois,
et les mammifères n'ont pas fait exception, enfin les mammaliaformes n'ont pas fait exception,
ils ont pris cher dans leur face !
Et donc ici vous avez l'exemple des marsupiaux notamment, les marsupiaux ont salement morflé.
donc, mais tous les mammaliaformes, je vous ai montré tout à l'heure la phylogénie vous aviez l'extension.
il y a que les multituberculés et les Australosphenidæ (donc les ancêtres des monotrèmes) et les placentaire et les marsupiaux
qui passeront au travers, mais comme j'ai dit, ça se fera pas sans heurts.
donc c'est une idée préconçue, c'est une idée commune
que les mammifères ont survécu à la limite crétacé-tertiaire mieux que les dinosaures.
Pas tant que ça dans la mesure où les dinosaures aujourd'hui sont 10 000 espèces alors qu'il y a que 5 000 espèces de mammifères.
Ben au final les dinosaures ont mieux survécu à la crise crétacé-tertiaire que les mammifères.
Donc voilà maintenant qu'on a passé en revue un petit peu ces mammifères mésozoïques,
on va voir ce qui arrive du côté des véritables mammifères, donc le clade Mammalia.
Donc le clade Mammalia, qui je le rappelle
comprend l'ancêtre des monotrèmes, des marsupiaux et des placentaires, et tous ses descendants.
Donc, il faut tracer la lignée des monotrèmes, des placentaires et des marsupiaux
pour aller chercher leurs ancêtres en commun qui se trouve ici. Donc ça là c'est l'ancêtre commun des Mammalia.
Et donc vous voyez que cet ancêtre commun des Mammalia, on le trouve
profondément dans le mésozoïque, ici au jurassique.
Donc déjà, première information : les Mammalia, les vrais Mammalia
n'apparaissent pas après le début du cénozoïque
comme c'est souvent dit dans les reportages, en réalité il était déjà là bien avant.
Alors comment distingue-t-on ces trois familles de mammifères modernes ?
Donc vous avez les monotrèmes, qui sont les plus basaux, et vous avez les marsupiaux et les placentaires.
Et ce qui va les distinguer, en fait, c'est leur biologie reproductrice.
donc les monotrèmes, évidemment sont ceux qui pondent des œufs.
Les marsupiaux sont ceux qui donnent naissance à des bébés qui vont grandir dans une poche, ce que vous voyez ici.
et les placentaires sont ceux qui donnent naissance à des bébés qui sont immédiatement
formé et quasiment autonome dès la naissance.
Donc voilà des œufs,
Bébé dans la poche marsupial qui n'est pas tout de suite autonome
et mammifères quasiment autonome dès la naissance.
Bon évidemment, il y a différents degrés de ce que j'appelle autonomie mais en gros voilà.
Par exemple un chat n'est pas tout à fait autonome quand il naît, voyez un bébé chaton, il n'a pas les yeux ouverts.
Mais çà, çà, c'est un marsupial quand il naît, ça c'est un kangourou.
Donc vous voyez ce que j'appelle autonome
pas du tout autonome ! Voilà c'est des petits vers, les pauvres marsupiaux quand ils naissent.
Alors les mamans leur font une petite autoroute entre le vagin et la poche
pour qu'ils puissent escalader les poils. Voilà donc avec leurs petites mains ils font des petites autoroute
pour que la larve marsupial
escalade les poils jusqu'à la poche.
Mais voilà, s'il n'y a pas la poche, il n'y a pas de marsupial en vie !
Voilà, c'est ça que je veux dire par autonomie.
Donc ça ça s'appelle un petit altricial,
et ça c'est un petit précoce, voilà.
Donc ils développement précoce, développement altricial donc développement prolongée après la naissance
et donc vous voyez que l'altricialité, c'est quand même plutôt un caractère primitif puisque les monotrèmes quand ils naissent
qu'ils sortent de leurs œuf, il ressemble aussi à des petites larves. Donc voilà.
Mais quand même l'absence d’œuf
soutient le clade que forment les marsupiaux et les placentaires qui s'appelle le clade des Theria.
Donc à l'intérieur des Theria, vous avez les Metatheria que sont les marsupiaux
et les Eutheria que sont les mammifères placentaires.
Il y a aussi une autre curiosité au niveau de la biologie reproductrice,
donc chez les mammifères placentaires et marsupiaux, donc chez les Theria encore une fois,
on a une division des sexes qui est typiquement mammalienne avec les mâles qui sont XY et les femelles qui sont XX.
Donc les mâles sont hétérozygotes pour les chromosomes sexuels,
alors que les femelles sont homozygotes.
Et bien chez les monotrèmes, ce n'est pas le cas.
Ce sont les mâles qui sont homozygotes et les femelles qui sont hétérozygotes.
Donc les mâles sont ZZ et les femelles sont ZW.
Exactement comme chez les reptiles les oiseaux etc.
Donc ça c'est le caractère primitif
Et donc les monotrèmes sont assez curieux de ce point de vue là :
on sait pas trop comment ça s'est fait finalement cette transformation des chromosomes sexuels,
mais il y a un moment où il y a un truc qui a changé.
Et donc ce qui va caractériser ces mammifères,tous ces mammifères, c'est la dent tribosphénique.
Donc la dent tribosphénique, comme vous pouvez le voir,
c'est une dent qui a trois cônes qui ne sont pas alignés, mais qui forment un triangle,
donc le protocône, le paracône est le métacône.
Donc primitivement, normalement, on a trois cônes.
Donc c'est ce que vous pouvez voir ici :
primitivement on a trois cônes qui sont alignés d'avant en arrière, donc c'est ce qu'ont retrouve chez les cynodontes.
et, finalement, les cuspides accessoires vont se déplacer latéralement, vers l'extérieur
pour former le paracone et le métacone
et le cône du milieu devient le protocone.
Donc protocone, paracone, métacone, c'est sur les dents du dessus. sur les dents du dessous on a
Et sur les dents du dessous, on a l'équivalent
qui sont le protoconide, paraconide, métaconide et un talonide.
Un talonide qui est lui même formé de trois cuspides que sont l'entoconide, l'hypoconide et l'hypoconulide.
Talonide qui sert finalement à l'occlusion du protocone.
Donc ça, ce protocone là, vient former un pilon
le talonide forme un bassin et finalement le pilon vient broyer la nourriture dans le bassin.
Donc, ce qui va vraiment caractériser les mammifères, c'est la mastication.
La mastication grâce à la dent tribosphénique qui permet finalement de
pilonner la nourriture à l'intérieur de la bouche.
Donc..., et le muscle masséter va être aussi très important chez les mammifères
puisque ils forment les joues.
C'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler le muscle zygomatique aussi,
certains l'appellent le muscle zygomatique, il est attaché à l'arcade jugale, ou arcade zygomatique,
et il forme les joues, et les joues c'est ce qui retient la nourriture à l'intérieur de votre bouche
et qui vous permet aussi de mâcher puisque
c'est un muscle qui se contracte pour ramener la mâchoire du bas contre la mâchoire du haut.
Donc la combinaison dents tribosphénique - joue faite par un muscle masséter,
ça caractérise les mammifères voilà.
Et tout cela permet la mastication.
Donc ce sont des caractères très importants,
et donc la dent tribosphénique, c'est la seule qui existe encore aujourd'hui.
On a vu plein d'autres types dentaire avant, qui n'ont rien donné après la crise crétacé-tertiaire.
La dent tribosphénique, c'est la seule qui fonctionne encore aujourd'hui
Mais à partir de ce schéma tribosphénique, et bien les mammifères ils vont partir complètement en sucette.
Voilà. Avant ça, vous aviez des poissons des reptiles et
des reptiles mammaliens, donc des thérapsides,
qui n'avait qu'une seule cuspide sur leurs dents.
Donc une seule cuspide qui pouvait être plus ou moins agrémenté d'autres dents
ou plus ou moins crénelée, voilà selon que vous étiez herbivore ou carnivore, plus ou moins recourbée.
Mais voilà, ça a limité beaucoup la variation. Après chez les mammifères, à partir de ce schéma tribosphénique,
vous allez avoir des dents aussi bizarre que celle là, donc ça c'est un "crabeater deal, donc c'est le phoque crabier,
vous allez avoir des dents extrêmement complexes comme celle de la souris ou bien celles
d'autres rongeurs ici que donc les "vole" ce sont les loirs.
Ici vous avez un wallaby, là vous avez une vache...
Donc vous allez avoir tout les types de dents qui vont évoluer à partir de cette dent tribosphénique :
des dents très coupantes comme celle du lion,
des dents écrasantes comme celles de l'homme du panda.
Donc voilà, la mastication et la complexité du dessin dentaire,
c'est la signature des mammifères, Mammalia
Et là, à partir de là, il y a des types dentaire
qu'on a mis en place et qui vont caractériser chaque groupe de mammifères.
Ces types dentaire, si on veut comprendre l'évolution des mammifères
et si on veut regarder les mammifères fossiles et être capable de les identifier,
bon je suis navré, mais il faut en passer par là, il faut les connaître.
Donc c'est pareil, je vous invite à revenir ici,
à ce point de la vidéo aussi souvent qu'il le faudra,
parce que je vais pas rappeler à chaque fois ce que veulent dire ces termes,
parce que ça prendrait trop de temps.
Donc je vais les expliquer une bonne fois pour toute ici,
et comme ça tous ces types dentaire, après vous pourrez revenir à cet endroit de la vidéo pour comprendre ce que ça veut dire
Donc, déjà on va distinguer deux types dentaires en fonction de la hauteur de la couronne.
Donc ces deux types dentaires c'est : brachyodonte et hypsodonte.
Donc les dents brachyodontes, c'est une couronne dentaire basse.
Donc ici vous avez la limite gencives extérieure, en pointillés.
Donc vous avez soit la couronne basse et dans ce cas là vous êtes brachyodontes,
ou vous avez une couronne haute, voire très haute, et dans ce cas là vous êtes hypsodonte.
Donc voilà, l'humain a typiquement une couronne basse, vous voyez ici la limite entre les racines et la couronne.
La couronne est relativement basse c'est typiquement une dent brachyodonte, c'est le type primitif.
Les chevaux, eux, ont une dent très dérivée.
Ils ont les dents avec des couronnes très très haute parce qu'ils sont adaptés un régime herbivores...
et herbivores, voire même graminées, et les graminées ellesont beaucoup de silice à l'intérieur de leur cellule,
et cette silice, elle est extrêmement abrasive, c'est un mécanisme de défense contre les herbivores.
et cette silice extrêmement abrasive, et bien les herbivores vont systématiquement
et de manière complètement convergentes, évoluer des dents à couronne très très haute, donc des dents hypsodontes
qui vont continuer à grandir même quand l'animal est adulte,
afin qu'il y ait toujours un petit peu de dents pour les écraser. Et donc que vous voyez ici,
c'est finalement un mix... Ce que vous voyez sur cette surface, la surface est extrêmement complexe chez le cheval.
c'est finalement un mix entre de l'émail
mais aussi de la dentine donc l'ivoire qui se trouvent normalement à l'intérieur de l'émail,
mais chez eux elle est complètement exposées à cause de l'usure dentaire
et vous avez aussi du cément. Le cément qui se trouve entre les...
entre les couche d'émail finalement. Donc
la dentine représente l'intérieur de la dent et le cément représente l'équivalent de la dentine mais à l'extérieur de la dent.
Donc l'homme n'a pas vraiment de cément, il n'y a que les herbivores qui ont du cément
Donc ça c'est la première chose donc, brachyodonte
c'est un type dentaire qu'on va associer globalement, c'est le type dentaire primitif
qu'on retrouve chez les insectivores les omnivores et les carnivores
L'hypsodontie, c'est le type qu'on retrouve chez les herbivores et plus particulièrement chez les ... "graminovores"
je vais dire, donc ceux qui mangent des graminées, en anglais on les appelle des "grazers",
donc on peut dire "graminovores" je pense.
Donc les frugivores vont se retrouver du côté brachyodonte par exemple,
ceux qui mangent des feuilles, les folivores, vont aussi être plutôt brachyodontes,
ou à l'intermédiaire entre hypsodonte et  brachyodonte.
Parce qu'évidemment, on va voir qu'il n'y a pas de limite solide entre les deux...
évidemment que pendant l'évolution les groupes d'herbivores vont commencer avec le type primitif brachyodonte
et vont être des folivores ou des frugivores
et vont s'adapter au fil du cénozoïque
à un régime plus graminovores ou pas.
Mais le cheval par exemple, c'est un exemple typique
d'animal qui va évoluer au fil du cénozoïque vers un type
de plus en plus hypsodonte, un type dentaire de plus en plus hypsodonte
Et ce, dû à l’aridification du climat : à la fin du mésozoïque il n'y a pas d'herbe.
à la fin du mésozoïque, il n'y a pas d'herbe !
Le cénozoïque commence, il y a des forêts partout, le climat est extrêmement chaud, il n'y a pas de calotte glaciaire !
c'est seulement à l'oligocène que la calotte glaciaire va arriver.
La glaciation va se produire pour la première fois au cénozoïque à l'oligocène donc 30 millions d'années.
Il y a 30 millions d'années à partir de maintenant.
Et c'est seulement là que les savanes et les steppes vont se répandre à travers le monde grâce à l'aridité
provoquée par cette glaciation. Donc la glaciation, elle refroidit le climat mais elle retient l'eau aussi.
donc il y a aridité et développement des savanes
et c'est seulement là qu'on va voir les premiers hypsodontes se développer.
Et donc en plus de ces deux types dentaires,
il y a trois autres types dentaires qui vont se superposer à cela
selon les types bunodonte, lophodonte et sélénodonte.
Donc le type bunodonte, c'est le type
qui est le plus proche de celui du type primitif.
Donc le type primitif c'est les dents d'insectivore,
donc c'est la dent tribosphénique, ce que je vous ai montré tout à l'heure,
donc l'opossum, typiquement,
Donc, c'est des cuspides qui sont relativement hautes et pointues.
Bon avec le type bunodonte,
on est toujours sur des cuspides relativement rondes mais beaucoup moins pointues.
Donc c'est typiquement ce qu'on rencontre chez le cochon et chez l'humain, donc chez les omnivores.
On rencontre ça chez l'ours aussi, le type bunodonte.
Donc le type bunodonte c'est la dent typique des omnivores.
Et ensuite vous avez les dents d'herbivores,
donc les dents lophodonte et sélénodonte.
Donc on va commencer par les dents lophodontes.
Les dents lophodontes, c'est assez simple vous avez le bord extérieur qui forment un mur
ou une muraille dentaire,
et à l'intérieur vous avez 2 lophes : 1 et 2
Donc votre protocone il est là, votre paracone il est là, métacone il est là et ça c'est l'hypocone.
Important l'hypocone : il n'est pas là primitivement donc si je retourne ici,
vous voyez, le protocone il est là, paracone, métcone
et vous avez un petit repli d'émail ici
qu'on appelle un cingulum  qui formera l'hypocone plus tard chez certaines espèces,
chez d'autres espèce l'hypocone, ça va être le métaconule qui s'est agrandie,
donc que ce soit dans un cas ou dans l'autre ça s'appelle un hypocone,
mais faut savoir que l'hypocone est quelque chose de convergent
parce que ça vient avec l'adaptation à l'herbivorie.
Donc les primates que nous sommes, nos ancêtres étaient
folivores et frugivores, ils ont développé un hypocone que vous voyez là.
proto.,  para., méta. et hypocone.
Ici, vous avez une dent de rhinocéros, donc voilà la dent en vrai.
Vous avez une dent de rhinocéros, proto., para., méta., hypo. et avec des lophes.
Et ici vous avez la dent sélénodonte, c'est typiquement la dent qu'on retrouve chez les ruminants.
Donc les vaches, les chèvres, les cerfs, les girafes, tout ça, ça a des dents sélénodontes,
Et là, c'est pareil, proto., para.,  meta. et hypocone.
Tout est là.
C'est de la dent typique d'herbivores, avec quatre cônes bien développés et la forme sélénodonte,
donc très typique des ruminants. Donc sélénodonte parce que en forme de croissant de lune tout simplement.
Et enfin le type carnivore, j'ai oublié de le mentionner, mais il y a évidemment le type carnivores.
C'est très simple, donc vous prenez une dent tribosphénique classique,
vous enlevez une des trois cuspides, vous gardez les deux sur le bord de la dent,
et ça vous donne un énorme tranchant que vous pouvez voir ici : donc deux sur le bord de la dents avec une lame tranchante au milieu
c'est la dent sécodonte, la dent qui sert à couper, donc là vous avez une hyène par exemple.
Bon voilà ! Et après vous faites des combinaisons, parce que ça se peut aussi.
Donc on peut faire des combinaisons de dent brachybunodonte, donc des dents à couronne basse et à morphologie bunodonte,
ça vous donne l'humain, ça vous donne le cochon, ça vous donne la dent typique des omnivores.
vous avez des dents brachylophodonte, c'est typiquement ce qu'on retrouve chez le tapir et c'est une dent typique de folivores.
Vous avez des dents hypsolophodonte,
c'est la dent de rhinocéros, c'est une dent de graminovores.
Vous avez des dents hypsosélénodonte, c'est la dent typique des vaches
et des chèvres par exemple, donc c'est une dent d'herbivores mangeurs de graminées
Sécodonte n'est jamais associé à l'hypsodontie,
donc ça ça simplifie les choses, c'est toujours brachysécodonte, donc on dit directement sécodonte.
Sélénodonte et quelquefois associée à brachyodonte, dans ce cas là ce sera plutôt folivores.
Mais brachysélénodonte, c'est plutôt un type dentaire qui se rencontrent chez les artiodactyle de l'éocène
donc on en parlera rapidement, mais voilà ,
c'est un type de dent qu'on ne rencontre plus vraiment chez les espèces modernes.
Et donc à partir de ces types dentaires, vous pouvez dériver absolument toutes les lignées de mammifères du monde.
Et c'est ça qui est formidable avec les mammifères, c'est que vous n'avez besoin que des dents.
Chaque espèce, et j'insiste dessus, il n'y a rien d'exagéré dans ce que je dis, chaque espèce à une morphologie de molaire différentes.
Vous pouvez reconnaître une espèce de mammifère rien qu'à sa morphologie dentaire.
Et l'évolution de ces types dentaire se suit de façon merveilleuse dans le registre fossile
à partir de la dent tribosphénique, donc c'est ce que vous voyez au milieu ici,
vous pouvez dériver tous ces types dentaires et ils sont tous
magnifiquement documentés par le registre fossile, donc par exemple,
vous commencez avec la tribosphénique, vous rajoutez un hypocone, ça vous donne une dent de primate.
Voilà une dent de primate, c'est jamais qu'une dent tribosphénique avec un hypocone en plus.
Vous prenez la dent tribosphénique, vous la simplifiez à mort, vous obtenez la dent sécodonte
des carnivores, donc vous voyez là, on a les cuspides latérales
celles qui sont vers l'extérieur, le protocone vers l'intérieur,
on réduit les cuspides à l'intérieur jusqu'à avoir une belle l'âme et ça vous donne le type carnivores.
Vous développez cette forme plus ou moins en w que vous voyez à l'extérieur;
vous le développez à mort et vous obtenez les chiroptères avec leurs dents dites zalambdodontes.
Vous partez du côté des rongeurs et des lapins,
alors là vous rajoutez un hypocone, puis après c'est la fête : vous faites ce que vous voulez
parce que les rongeurs on va voir c'est juste du grand n'importe quoi leur morphologie dentaire, ils ont tout inventé.
Vous prenez la dent tribosphénique, vous la rendez lophodonte, vous rajoutez un hypocone,
vous développez la lophodontie et ensuite vous rajoutez des lophes,
voilà donc deux lophes chez Moeritherium
1, 2, 3 et puis ensuite 4 et puis ensuite jusqu'à ...pff... des vingtaines de lophes,
mais c'est juste une multiplication des lophes et vous obtenez un éléphant.
Voilà. Juste par multiplication des lophes.
Donc évidemment il y a des contraintes génétique à tout ça,
mais à partir du moment où le chemin à l'ajout dé l'offre est ouvert dans l'évolution des éléphants,
vous avez cette évolution à partir d'une dent tribosphénique,
jusqu'à cette espèce de monstre qui a une dent d'éléphant,
ça pèse jusqu'à 3, 4 voire 5 kg une dent d'éléphant donc c'est vraiment monstrueux.
Mais tout ça ça a commencé avec une dent tribosphénique et c'est très bien documentées par les fossiles.
vous développez la lophodontie du côté des périssodactyles
et si vous restez bunolophodonte, ça vous donne un tapir,
si vous donnez buno...
si vous devenez hypsolophodonte vous devenez un rhinocéros,
si vous devenez hypsolophodonte et que vous aimez vous compliquer la vie, ça donne à cheval.
Mais vous voyez que ça commence avec du lophodonte, le lophodont devient hypsodonte et après il y a des, des, des ...
des cuspides additionnels qui se développent et qui s'usent, ce qui donne la morphologie du cheval,
mais on reconnaît toujours proto, para, meta et hypocone chez le cheval.
Et puis vous avez la lignée des artiodactyle,
donc avec le développement de la sélénodontie que vous pouvez suivre de ce côté là chez les ruminants, ici,
ou bien le développement de la bunodontie chez les cochons et d'une, alors une euh...
bunodontie additionnée à de l'hypsodontie qui est aussi unique à l'hippopotame.
Donc on peut être bunodonte et hypsodonte, l'hippopotame est un bon exemple.
Donc voilà ça c'est la magie des dents chez les mammifères vous pouvez absolument tout faire
en paléo-mammalogie, à partir du moment où vous trouvez des dents et, ce qui est formidable, c'est que les dents étant faites d'émail,
c'est à dire étant déjà à 90% de la pierre
ni plus ni moins, c'est déjà 90% cristallisé l'émail. Il n'y a que 10% de tissus mous dans l'émail.
Bah, c'est basiquement déjà de la roche quoi, ça fossilise très très bien.
Mais évidemment, la dent tribosphénique n'est pas la seule innovation des mammifères, les mammifères ils ont d'autres innovations
et notamment,
l'oreille moyenne, alors l'oreille moyenne, on aura l'occasion d'en reparler quand on parlera de l'évolution des synapside.
Mais les os de l'oreille moyenne sont complètement détachés de la mâchoire inférieure chez les mammifères,
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle le sulcus de Meckel ou
la gouttière de Meckel, donc c'est ce que vous voyez ici en marron.
Donc, chez les synapsides, on avait plusieurs os à l'intérieur de la mâchoire, mais ces eaux se sont tous réduits et se sont transformées
en espèces de...
gloubiboulga osseux, voilà, qui se trouve à l'arrière de la mâchoire, ici.
et ce gloubiboulga osseux, il se trouve dans ce qu'on appelle le sillon ou la gouttière de Meckel, donc ce que vous voyez en marron ici.
Et chez les mammifères,
même si on trouve pas toujours le gloubiboulga  ousseux,
on trouve au moins le sucus qui correspond à ce gloubiboulga osseux et il se trouve que chez les mammifères
modernes bas, il n'y a pas de sucus comme ça. Vous regardezt la mâchoire, il n'y a pas du tout de
cette trace de trucs marron. Par contre, ce qu'il y a d'intéressant, c'est qu'en fait apparemment
ça s'est perdu de façon convergente, les monotrèmes l'ont perdue d'un côté et les Theria l'ont perdu de l'autre.
Donc ça c'est plutôt intéressant. Mais on reverra tout ça en détail, l'évolution des des os de la mâchoire.
Les mammifères, ils ont aussi la capacité de faire la pronation-supination.
Donc pronation-supination, vous prenez votre main à l'endroit, vous la retournez, vous la mettez à l'envers voilà.
Vous êtes le seul animal sur terre à arriver à faire ça ! les reptiles, les crocodiles, les...
les dinosaures n'étaient pas capables, les...
les amphibiens n'en sont pas capables, les oiseaux n'en sont pas capables.
Bref seuls les mammifères sont capables de faire ce mouvement de retourner votre main complètement,
parce que votre radius et votre ulna sont capables de se croiser, ce qui n'est pas le cas chez les autres amniotes.
Donc, ça c'est quelque chose de tout con pour nous, mais c'est formidable en réalité.
Donc, évidemment beaucoup de mammifères ont perdu ensuite secondairement cette capacité,
notamment ceux qui se sont adaptés à la course, donc comme les carnivores et les herbivores.
Donc beaucoup de carnivores et de grands herbivores, comme les ongulés, vont perdre cette adaptation,
mais si vous regardez les mammifères qui ont gardé le type primitif,
et ben ils sont tous capables de faire ça, donc les écureuils par exemple sont capables de le faire.
Ensuite dans la jambe, parce qu'il n'y a pas que le bras dans la vie.
Dans la jambe, vous avez le calcanéum, donc l'os du talon qui se trouve en dessous de l'astragale, c'est-à-dire l' os de la cheville.
Chez les mammifères donc, l'astragale est le seul os qui s'articule avec le reste de la jambe.
Donc ici le tibia et la fibula.
Donc l'astragale est le seul os qui s'articule avec la jambe, ce n'est pas le cas chez les reptiles.
Chez les reptiles, l'astragale s'articule avec le tibia,
le calcanéum s'articule avec la fibula.
Donc vous avez une double articulation du pied avec la jambe.
Pas chez les mammifères. Vous n'avez que l'astragale.
Donc ça c'est aussi un caractère ostéologique des mammifères et bien sûr les mammifères
ont acquis la lactation, donc la capacité de nourrir les petits avec du lait.
Donc chez les monotrèmes, ça s'effectue par des glandes mammaires qui sont dispersés sur un patch euh...
ventrale. Donc en fait les monotrèmes suintent du lait, mais n'ont pas vraiment de...
enfin ils ont des glandes mammaires, mais ils n'ont pas vraiment de deux mamelons.
Donc qu'il suintent juste du lait qui est léchée par les petits monotrèmes, par les petits bébés ornithorynque, là par exemple.
D'ailleurs les monotrèmes nous montrent qu'en fait, c'est bel et bien une glande, une glande sudoripare, une glande à sueur qui a évolué.
Alors c'est un mélange de glandes à sueur et de glande à sébum, en fait.
Donc le gras des cheveux, c'est ça le sébum,
et ben c'est la mix entre la sueur et le sébum qui forment le lait.
Ouais je sais c'est dégueulasse, mais ça se suit très bien,
embryologiquement, ça se voit très bien et les monotrèmes ont typiquement, les glandes mammaires des monotrèmes sont encore vraiment
très similaires à des glandes à sueur, elles sont même encore associé à des poils.
Et c'est aussi le cas chez les marsupiaux. Chez les marsupiaux vous avez un téton, vous avez un mamelon,
mais le mamelon est encore associé à des poils. Donc il y a guère que chez les placentaires en fait,
qu'il n'y a plus l'association avec les poils et que la glande mammaire est méconnaissable en fait.
Mais en réalité, les glandes sudoripares et à sébum sont les glandes qui ont donné
les glandes mammaires, donc on les appelle aussi les glandes apocrines, voilà.
♫ C'est dégueulasse... ♫
Et à propos de dégueulasseté chez les monotrèmes, bah on va parler des monotrèmes, voilà !
Ça fait déjà un bon moment que ça dure, donc si vous voulez faire une petite pause, allez y, mettez vous bien,...
prenez un petit café, un petit coca, rafraîchissez-vous. Ça dépend s'il fait chaud ou froid aujourd'hui.
Voilà, on va commencer maintenant à parler, donc du registre fossile de chacun de ces grands groupes de mammifères, à savoir
les monotrèmes, les marsupiaux; on terminera par les placentaire et notamment la phylogénie des placentaires.
Donc pas encore tout de suite le registre fossile des placentaires, parce que ça va vraiment faire tout le reste.
Parce qu'il faut savoir, c'est qu'on a un registre fossile des placentaires qui est beaucoup plus riche que pour les monotrèmes ou les marsupiaux.
Mais ça je vais vous en convaincre dans les prochaines slides. Donc c'est pour ça qu'après, on va passer beaucoup beaucoup de temps sur les placentaires,
alors qu'on va basiquement parler des monotrèmes et des marsupiaux
QUE aujourd'hui. On reparlera un petit peu des marsupiaux pour l'épisode sur l'Amérique du Sud,
parce qu'on verra qui s'est passé des choses très intéressantes en Amérique du Sud à propos des marsupiaux, mais voilà.
Puis bon de toute façon nous ne sommes pas australiens donc globalement,
les monotrèmes et les marsupiaux, ça ne forme pas la faune de notre quotidien.
Donc ça nous intéresse moyennement. les mammifères qui nous entoure les chiens, les chats,
les vaches, les cochons, tout ça c'est du placentaire, et les humains évidemment sont aussi des mammifères placentaires.
Donc on n'est pas vraiment en contact direct avec les monotrèmes au quotidien, ni avec des marsupiaux d'ailleurs.
Et même le registre fossile des marsupiaux dans le reste du monde,
à part en Australie et en Amérique du Sud, c'est assez maigrichon. Mais on va voir ça en temps utile.
Donc c'est parti maintenant pour les monotrèmes !
Donc les monotrèmes donc, aujourd'hui il n'y a plus que
l'ornithorynque - platypus en anglais - et l'échidné,
les deux échidnés, il y a deux espèces d'échidné qui survivent.
Donc, et tous les deux appartiennent à des types écologiques qui sont extrêmement différents mais aussi extrêmement spécialisés.
donc l'ornithorynque c'est un mammifère aquatique piscivore ou pas piscivore mais plutôt "invertébrivore".
Bon, il mange aussi du poisson, mais il mange surtout des invertébrés,
des petits des petits verres des larves des choses comme ça.
"hakuna matata"
Et l'échidné, bah c'est un fourmilier, c'est un mangeur de fourmis et de termites.
Donc voilà, ces deux types écologiques extrêmement spécialisés, donc de ce fait l'échidné et
l'ornithorynque ont des tronches. C'est ce qu'on appelle des mammifères à tronche.
Vous pouvez voir que le crâne de l'échidné est complètement édenté et a cette espèce de long museau très fin qu'on retrouve systématiquement
chez les fourmiliers. Pourquoi ? parce qu'il a une très très longue langue. Donc il y a ce trail très long museau très fin il y a une très longue langue
et il n'a pas de dents parce que, quand vous avez une très longue langue qui s'accroche à tout ce qui passe,
y compris à de la terre et que vous mettez à mastiquer de la terre avec vos dents, bah vous finissez avec des abcès gros comme n'importe quoi.
Donc il y a une très très forte sélection naturelle contre la présence de dents chez les mammifères fourmilier.
Enfin adapté au mode de vie fourmilier. Donc on va avoir ça de façon récurrente chez les mammifères.
Et l'ornithorynque, alors l'ornithorynque c'est intéressant parce qu'il n'a pas de dents non plus,
mais par contre, il a des dents de lait.
donc il n'a pas de dents à l'âge adulte, mais il a des dents de lait et ...
Un ornithorynque fossiles du nom de Obdurodon
est un ornithorynque géant avec des grosses dents même à l'âge adulte.
Et ça c'est très intéressant, parce que ça veut dire que c'est un phénomène récent la perte des dents chez l'ornithorynque.
Obdurodon vivaient au pléistocène donc il y a moins de deux millions d'années.
Il a la tronche d'un ornithorynque juste qu'il est géant et il a des dents.
Et ce qu'il y a d'intéressant, c'est que grâce à Obdurodon, on sait à quoi ressemblaient les dents d'ornithorynque.
Et du coup, on peut être sûr qu'elles étaient tribosphéniques. Et grâce à Obdurodon, on est capable de tracer
la morphologie des dents, l'évolution de la morphologie des dents, depuis le type tribosphénique primitif.
Donc ici vous avez un des plus vieux fossile
de monotrème qu'on connaisse, c'est Steropodon du crétacé d'Australie. Donc pour une lignée qui serait apparu au début du
jurassique, c'est pas génial mais le registre fossile des monotrèmes indiquent qu'ils n'ont jamais quitté l'Australie
Donc déjà sa limite considérablement la surface de recherche
quand on veut chercher du monotrème fossile. Et puis le registre fossile australien, pour ce qui est du mésozoïque,
il n'est pas grandiose grandiose.
Il y a des sites pas mal.
Mais ce sont des patchs en fait. Donc il y a des sites qui fournissent beaucoup de matériel,
mais comme ils sont très limitées dans le temps, bah du coup ça aide pas.
Donc voici Steropodon, c'est une mandibule et on reconnaît... donc on voit bien la morphologie tribosphénique de ses dents.
Ce qu'il y a d'intéressant aussi avec Steropodon, c'est que c'est un fossile opalisé.
C'est donc un fossile en pierres semi précieuses, et ça c'est quand même la classe !
Voilà, quelques caractères typiques des monotrèmes, il y a aussi un os épipubique
chez les monotrèmes, donc là vous le voyez ici donc ça c'est le pelvis enfin le
bassin du coup, et à l'avant du bassin vous voyez des petits os épipubiques.
Donc voilà, on parle souvent des os marsupiaux chez les marsupiaux du coup, on parle d'os marsupiaux.
Bah les os marsupiaux, c'est des os épipubiques ou prépubiques, prépubiens du coup.
Donc, et des os épipubiens,
du coup ils ne sont pas typiques des marsupiaux en réalité, ils sont présents chez les monotrèmes,
et en réalité ils sont présents chez énormément de mammaliaformes du mésozoïque les os épipubiens.
Et donc ça veut pas... donc vous entendrez souvent dire que les os marsupiaux servent à porter une poche.
Mais en fait non, les monotrèmes n'ont pas de poche et il est très fort probable que
les os épipubiens n'aient jamais servi à porter de poche.
D'ailleurs quand on dissèque des marsupiaux aujourd'hui, ce qui n'est pas évident parce qu'il faut des...
aval (?) d'autorisation mais
il y a des gens qui l'ont fait par le passé donc on peut encore se référer à leur description, mais quand on dissèque un marsupial,
la poche et pas attachés aux os épipubiens. Pas du tout !
Il y a des muscles abdominaux qui sont attachés là, mais ils ont rien à voir avec la poche. Donc voila !
Et autre caractère intéressant les monotrèmes, en tout cas chez les mâles, ont une espèce de pointe osseuse à l'arrière du talon.
Donc ce qui s'appelle un "tarsal spur" en anglais, donc ils ont une espèce de pointe osseuse à l'arrière du talon sur les pattes arrières
et qui est empoisonnée chez le mâle ornithorynque.
Donc, et ça c'est un caractère qui... enfin le venin,
le fait de même d'avoir du venin, c'est un caractère qui fait vraiment beaucoup penser aux reptiles,
de manière générale et qu'on associe rarement aux mammifères.
Bien qu'évidemment il y ait quand même pas mal d'espèces de mammifères
comme le Solenodon des caraïbes, ou les certaines espèces de loris, donc des primates, qui soient... qui soient venimeuse.
Mais quand même, le fait d'être venimeux, c'est quand même quelque chose qu'on veut associer plus volontiers aux reptiles.
Donc voilà, c'est la seule diapo que j'aurai sur le registre fossile des monotrèmes parce que, ben comme j'ai dit,
quand vous regardez Steropodon, vous avez quasiment un quart du registre fossile et des monotrèmes.
Donc voilà. C'est un peu, c'est un peu triste, mais il n'y a pas beaucoup beaucoup de fossiles de monotrèmes
et ils sont tous en Australie.
Évidemment les monotrèmes sont aussi connues, notamment les échidnés, ils sont connus pour avoir
quatre glands au pénis. Donc ce qui vous montre que le pénis était autrefois une structure paire.
Donc voilà ça c'est le pénis,
c'est le pénis de notre cher ami l'échidné avec ses quatre glands.
Maintenant on monte gentiment la phylogénie vers les mammifères terriens, donc les Theria.
Alors les mammifères Theria se distinguent des monotrèmes par plusieurs caractères ostéologiques. Premièrement l'alisphénoïde.
Donc l'alisphénoïde, c'est un os de la boîte crânienne, on en reparlera chez les cynodontes,
chez les synapsides en général donc.
Chez les synapsides, l'alisphénoïde était quasiment absent ; chez les cynodontes, on a un os qui s'appelle le présphénoïde,
pardon l'épiptérigoïde - houla, je fatigue - l'épiptérigoïde
qui est tout petit, et qui participent à la constitution de la boîte crânienne,
et en fait il y a une tendance à l'agrandissement de l'alisphénoïde tout au long de la lignée des mammaliaformes,
et cet agrandissement culmine donc chez les mammifères Theria, chez qui l'alisphénoïde est
très largement l'os dominant, enfin pas très largement, mais est un des os dominants de la boîte crânienne.
Et cette alisphénoïde,
particulièrement chez les Theria, il est plus grand que la partie de l'os pétreux
qui participent à la boîte crânienne. Donc cette partie de l'os pétreux qui participe à la boîte crânienne, c'est une petite lame d'os
qui se trouve à l'avant de l'os qui contient la cochlée, donc la cochlée l'oreille interne que vous voyez ici,
sont entourés par un os ce qui s'appelle le pétreux. Et ce pétreux, il émet une petite lame à l'avant
qui participe à la boîte crânienne, c'est la petrosal lamina.
Et donc l'alisphénoïde en fait, prend la place du pétreux,
littéralement la petrosal lamina fini par disparaître chez les mammifères Theria.
Autre caractère intéressant du pétreux, c'est la cochlée. Donc à l'intérieur du pétreux, la cochlée fait au moins un tour,
et elle peut faire jusqu'à neuf tours chez les mammifères Theria, mais il y a toujours au moins un tour.
Chez les vaches et les monotrèmes, en fait la cochlée juste en forme de "L".
Donc la cochlée osseuse du moins, la cochlée...
en tissus mous est un peu différente, mais la cochlée osseuse,
elle est juste en forme de "L" chez les monotrèmes.
Donc elle est un peu plus simple. Là, vous avez une cochlée un peu plus enroulée qui fait au moins un tour, sur elle-même.
Vous perdez les côtes sur l'atlas, donc l'atlas qui est le premier os,
enfin qui est la première vertèbre du cou,
donc, d'où son nom "atlas" comme le héros grec qui portait le monde, bon bah l'atlas c'est la première vertèbre, celle qui porte le crâne.
et il n'y a plus de côtes sur cet atlas, donc ça ça achève une tendance qu'on verra chez les synapsides qui est
la différenciation des différentes parties de la colonne vertébrale.
Chez les reptiles, toutes les vertèbres ou presque sont les mêmes.
Toutes les vertèbres se ressemblent du cou à la queue et elles ont toutes des côtes.
Et on va voir qu'en fait les côtes vont être perdus sur les vertèbres lombaires,
elles vont s'agrandir sur les vertèbres thoraciques
et les vertèbres cervicales vont aussi perdre leurs côtes,
l'atlas étant l'ultime vertèbre, l'ultime vertèbre à perdre ses côtes.
Ce qui implique du coup que les monotrèmes avaient un
atlas sur le..., avaient des vertèbres sur leur atlas toutes petites vertèbres mais ils les ont.
Et l'astragale, donc on a parlé tout à l'heure de l'astragale, l' os de la cheville
donc qui porte l'articulation avec la jambe, et bien, développe ce qu'on appelle un cou.
Donc c'est une petite constriction en fait, entre la face articulaire qui
s'articule avec la jambe et la face articulaire qui s'articule avec le reste du pied.
Maintenant vous avez cette petite constriction que vous voyez là, ici.
Et cette petite constriction est typique des mammifères Theria.
Donc ça ce sont les caractères, finalement, qu'on retrouve à la fois chez les marsupiaux, mais aussi chez les placentaires.
Donc ce qu'il y a d'intéressant, c'est que beaucoup de gens pensent en fait
que les marsupiaux sont plus primitifs que les placentaires et que, du coup, on devrait trouver des marsupiaux
avant les placentaires dans le registre fossile.
C'est une idée fausse, il s'agit de deux groupes frères donc qui sont autant dérivés l'un que l'autre.
Et en réalité, bien que les marsupiaux étaient dominants sur les placentaires au mésozoïque.
Parce que, oui, il y a aussi des histoires de dominance entre les espèces qui ne sont pas dominantes.
Mais voilà,
les marsupiaux étaient très nombreux et très diversifiés au mésozoïque. Ils ont pris une grande claque à la crise crétacé-paléogène.
Mais bien qu'ils aient été dominants, et bien c'est... Le premier mammifère Theria
est un placen..., est en fait un mammifère Eutheria, donc il est plus proche des placentaires
que des Metatheria, c'est à dire les marsupiaux.
Après si vous voulez une petite distinction, je vais utiliser Eutheria et Metatheria
de façon synonymes à placentaires et marsupiaux respectivement.
Mais en réalité, en fait les placentaire sont un
sous-groupe à l'intérieur des Eutheria, donc il existe des Eutheria qui ne sont pas des placentaires, mais ils sont quand même plus
étroitement apparenté aux placentaires
qu'aux marsupiaux.
Et donc les Metatheria
inclut les marsupiaux et vous avez des Metatheria qui ne sont pas des marsupiaux, mais qui sont plus
apparentés et aux marsupiaux qu'aux placentaires.
Donc là par exemple vous avez Juramaia qui est le tout premier Eutheria, donc ce n'est pas un placentaires, mais
il est plus étroitement apparenté aux placentaires qu'à n'importe quoi d'autres.
donc jura maya qui nous vient du jurassique de chine possède le seul et unique
caractère placentaire qu'on retrouve chez absolument tous les placentaires,
parce que les placentaire sont si diversifiés que...
qu'en fait c'est très très dur de trouver un caractère qui se retrouve chez tous.
Mais il y a ce caractère là au moins.
Et ce caractère qu'on retrouve chez tous les Eutheria pardon (pas les placentaires), et bien c'est la présence de trois molaires :
une, deux, trois et une prémolaires qui est
molariforme, c'est à dire une prémolaires qui est plus grosse que les autres prémolaires, et donc qui ressemble à une molaire, donc voilà.
Une molaire, deux molaires, trois molaires et une 4e... et une dernière prémolaires.
Donc qui peut être la quatrième ou la cinquième parce qu'à l'époque les Eutheria ils avaientt 5...
ils pouvaient avoir 5 prémolaires, ça les dérangeait pas.
Donc une dernière prémolaires qui est plus grosse en fait que les autres prémolaires.
Et ça se voit aussi sur les dents du dessus, donc ça c'est les dents du dessus, vous voyez très bien la
morphologie tribosphénique d'ailleurs.
Une molaire, deux molaires, 3 molaires. Ici vous avez des prémolaires et ici vous l'avez la dernière
des prémolaires qui est très semblable à une molaire, donc c'est
le seul caractère que vous trouverez de façon constante chez les Eutheria.
C'est pas d'autres caractères que ça. Bah évidemment, il y a le caractère qui est de donner naissance à des petits qui sont autonomes,
Mais ça dans le registre fossile vous le verrez pas !
évidemment !
Donc on n'utilise que ces caractères dentaires
Et en quoi ça diffère, du cout, des Metatheria, donc des marsupiaux ? bah parce que les marsupiaux ils ont
non pas trois mais quatre molaires.
Donc pourquoi faire simple !
Pourquoi faire simple quand on est un placentaire, au lieu d'avoir quatre molaires, les placentaire, en fait, ils ont trois molaires et une dernière
prémolaires qui ressemble à une molaire. Voilà ! Au lieu d'avoir les quatre molaires
des mammifères Metatheria. Donc chez les Metatheria, chez les marsupiaux, on va avoir trois prémolaires et quatre molaires,
alors que chez les Eutheria, on va avoir quatre ou cinq prémolaires et 3 molaires.
Alors évidemment la cinquième prèm... enfin la...
La plupart des Eutheria modernes, ce qu'on va voir au cénozoïque ont perdu la cinquième
prémolaires donc il y a que 4 prémolaires. Donc globalement c'est le schéma
inverse en fait des Metatheria. Vous avez 3 molaires 4 prémolaires chez les Eutheria
et vous avez 4 molaires 3 prémolaires chez les Metatheria.
Voilà, c'est simple non ?
Alors. maintenant, on divise, on plonge à l'intérieur des Theria et maintenant nous sommes chez les marsupiaux.
Donc on va regarder d'abord la branche des marsupiaux pour ensuite
la laisser derrière nous et pouvoir se focaliser uniquement sur la branche des placentaires.
Les marsupiaux donc. Et bien les marsupiaux du clade Metatheria,
à l'intérieur duquel on trouve Marsupialia.
Et bien comme je vous l'ai dit, il se caractérise par la présence de quatre molaires,
et ils ont aussi une autre particularité au niveau de leurs dents, c'est que,
en plus d'avoir quatre molaires,
il n'y a en réalité que la dernière des prémolaires qui se renouvelle. Donc la dernière des prémolaires qui normalement est la troisième prémolaire.
Donc ,1-2-3 prémolaires ; un deux trois quatre molaires.
Et vu qu'il n'y a que la dernière des prémolaires qui se renouvelle,
au lieu d'avoir toutes les molaires en...
sous la forme de dents de lait, avant de les avoir sous forme adulte.
Et bien, vu qu'il n'y a que la dernière des prémolaires qui est renouvelée et bien généralement vous allez voir ce que vous voyez très bien sûr ce diagramme :
c'est que la dernière prémolaire, en fait, elle est beaucoup moins usée que les molaires qu'il y a derrière elle.
Donc ça vous fait une quatrième prémolaire
très pointue à côté de molaires qui sont déjà usées en fait Et l'usure se voit très bien sur la...
sur les molaires, puisque les cuspides, notamment chez les Didelphimorphia, donc chez les opossums,
sont très pointues.
Bon évidemment, la diversité des marsupiaux ne se limite pas qu'aux opossums,
mais l'opossum c'est vraiment le marsupial typique.
Un autre caractère important chez les marsupiaux : c'est aussi le nombre d'incisives.
Donc typiquement chez les placentaires, on n'a que 3 incisives, alors que chez les marsupiaux vous voyez
là on en a cinq... 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 sur la mâchoire supérieure et sur la mâchoire inférieure on en a quatre.
Donc c'est aussi un caractère qui est important chez les marsupiaux le nombre d'incisives est primitivement...
Ils retiennent le nombre d'incisives primitive. Ils n'ont pas réduit leur nombre d'incisives comme c'est arrivé chez les placentaires.
Enfin, un dernier caractère qui est pas totalement unique aux marsupiaux mais qui est quand même bien pratique
si jamais on n'est pas à l'aise avec les dents, c'est l'os jugal.
Donc l'os jugal chez les marsupiaux, il s'arrête pas au milieu de l'arcade zygomatique
comme chez la plupart des placentaires. Il s'étend vers l'arrière jusqu'à l'articulation de la mâchoire qui se trouve ici.
Donc le jugal participe à l'articulation de la mâchoire et ça c'est aussi un caractère qui est présent chez tous les marsupiaux,
mais qu'on retrouve très rarement par contre chez les placentaire. Bon par contre, on le retrouve quelques fois, par exemple chez les damans typiquement.
Donc il arrive que, voilà, ce caractère soit présent chez les placentaires.
Mais bon si vous n'êtes pas à l'aise avec les caractères dentaires ou si vous avez un petit doute.
Bon, quand même, quand vous trouvez 5 incisives, y a pas de doute à avoir, mais bon.
Voilà, si vous avez un petit doute,
vous pouvez toujours checker le jugal et voir si ça colle aussi avec une morphologie de marsupial.
Donc l'os épipubiens ou os marsupial, comme je l'ai dis, n'est pas typique des marsupiaux.
Donc ça, c'est pas possible.
Donc ça c'est... bon c'est.. Par contre, il est absent chez les placentaire, ça c'est à noter.
Encore que, il existe une théorie selon laquelle,
l'os épipubien serait en fait l'ancêtre entre guillemets du baculum.
Mais ça on en reparlera à l'épisode sur les carnivores si vous le voulez bien.
Donc, ici vous avez un exemple de marsupial africain, ce qui me permet de vous dire que, en fait,
bah,  les marsupiaux était très largement dominants au crétacé,
ils prennent une grosse claque à la crise crétacé-tertiaire.
Mais ils reprennent du poil de la bête
au début du cénozoïque, et notamment à l'éocène, où ils ont une deux une distribution absolument mondiale.
Donc vous avez Ghamidtherium en Afrique donc ici dans l'éocène d’Égypte.
Mais vous avez aussi la Sarigue de Cuvier donc le fameux opossum de Montmartre
que Cuvier avait préparé, enfin la légende dit que Cuvier l'a préparé devant
la foule ébahie en prédisant qu'il aurait un os marsupial et pouf ! il a dégagé l'os marsupial et voilà.
Donc la fameuse histoire de la sarigue de Cuvier, ben la sarigue de Cuvier était un marsupial, c'était un petit opossum
de l'oligocène de Montmartre. Donc voilà, les marsupiaux étaient aussi présents en France.
Ils étaient présents absolument partout et pas seulement en Australie et en Amérique du Sud, comme ils le sont aujourd'hui.
Donc cette réduction de...
cette restriction finalement à l’Amérique du Sud et à l’Australie, ce ne sont que des refuges au final,
et les restes un peu maigrichons d'une belle diversité passée, quoi.
Et comme on a montré le gland,
enfin, le gland à quatre extrémités finalement des monotrèmes,
bah je vous fais remarquer au passage que les marsupiaux eux ils ont deux glands.
Et maintenant vous commencez à faire la connexion avec le fait que, les placentaires n'ont plus qu'un gland.
Donc voilà. On a cette tendance évolutive à la réduction du nombre de glands.
bon c'est pas pour autant qu'on n'a pas de glands parmi les placentaires, évidemment.
Petit jeu de mots. Petit jeu de mots... je... ça fait longtemps que je parle, maintenant je commence à avoir de l'humour pourri !
Donc les marsupiaux, ce qu'il y a d'intéressant, c'est de regarder leur diversité.
Diversité qui n'a finalement,
malgré leur réduction leur restriction géographique, leur diversité n'a rien à envier à celle des placentaires.
Donc on a de l'arboricole, par exemple le koala, on a du...
de l'équivalent des écureuils volants avec le sugar glider,
on a du rongeur avec les bandicoots,
(oui d'ailleurs Crash Bandicoot est inspiré d'un vrai animal australien qui s'appelle un bandicoot,
pour les vieux de la vieille qui se rappelle de ce que c'est que Crash Bandicoot, évidemment)
vous avez des taupes, donc ici Notoryctes, la taupe marsupial qui comme certaines taupe européenne, a des grosses...
enfin comme certaines taupe placentaire a de très grosses mains pour creuser et
avec des gros doigts en forme de pelles
et n'a pas d'yeux. Donc les yeux sont complètement recouvert par de la fourrure, c'est ce qu'on retrouve par exemple chez taupe dorée africaine.
Vous avez Chironectes qui est le seul marsupial aquatique, enfin semi-aquatique pour le coup, on va en reparler un petit peu.
Évidemment le kangourou, alors le kangourou qui a une tête de chameau sur un corps de rats sauteurs géants.
Donc là pour le coup, il n'y a pas d'équivalent chez les placentaires du kangourou.
Et donc, Chironectes, j'aimerais bien parler un petit peu de Chironectes donc.
Peut-être certain d'entre vous se sont demandé pourquoi il n'existait pas de baleine marsupiale
et de chauve-souris marsupial parce que c'est vrai qu'au final, vous avez ici une diversité qui est... alors si je mets cette diapos là.
Vous avez ici une diversité finalement qui est très semblable à ce qu'on rencontre chez les mammifères placentaires.
Donc à gauche, vous avez les mammifères placentaires et à droite vous avez leur équivalent marsupial.
Donc des trucs que j'ai passé par exemple, c'est le
"tasmanian wolf", donc le loup de Tasmanie, qui est l'équivalent marsupial du loup.
Et vous avez l'équivalent de... des fourmiliers qui est le numbat, voilà. Bon vous avez aussi l'échidné qui fait office de
de fourmilier en Australie mais c'est pas un marsupial.
Mais voilà.
l'idée c'est que, les marsupiaux finalement, ils ont fait en Australie ce que les placentaire ont fait partout ailleurs,
donc la question c'est, pourquoi il n'y a pas de baleines ni de...
ni de chiroptères (ni de chauves-souris)
Bah...
ça viendrait en fait peut-être de leur développement.
Donc rappelez-vous les marsupiaux quand ils sortent de leurs du... quand ils...  quand la femelle marsupial accouche, elle accouche d'une petite larve
qui finalement n'a qu'une tête et des bras, voilà. Et le reste c'est vermiforme quoi, donc c'est une larve vraiment !
Sauf que les bras, à l'intérieur des bras, les os sont extrêmement ossifiés. Vous pouviez même voir qu'il y avait des petits doigts.
Et bien, et je vous invite à retourner vers ce passage-là de la vidéo si vous voulez vérifier,
donc vous pouvez même voir qu'il ya des petits doigts
Et du coup, ça veut dire que le marsupial, quand il naît,
doit avoir des bras avec des doigts déjà différencié, pour pouvoir se traîner jusqu'à la poche.
Et ça, ça met une contrainte évolutive énorme sur la forme que les bras peuvent avoir chez les marsupiaux.
Ce qui fait que les bras ne peuvent pas évoluer en ailes ou en nageoires,
comme ils le peuvent chez les placentaires. Du mois, c'est une des explications qui a été avancé et je la trouve extrêmement élégante.
C'est ce qu'on appelle typiquement une contrainte développementale, donc l'évolution ne peut pas tout faire en fait, et des marsupiaux en sont victimes.
Et c'est pour ça que Chironectes, d'ailleurs si on revient, c'est pour ça que Chironectes, vous voyez ici,
il a les pieds palmés mais il n'a pas les bras palmés !
haha ! Aviez-vous remarqué ?
Bon évidemment, vous avez un contre-exemple juste là qui est
la taupe marsupial qui a des gros doigts en forme de pelle. Mais bon, c'est quand même des doigts. Ça reste des doigts.
Et quand on regarde un peu la phylogénie des marsupial ce qu'il y a d'intéressant à noter, c'est que vous avez vous avez en gros les marsupiaux
qui sont en amérique du sud
qui sont bien distincts dans la phylogénie des marsupiaux qu'on trouve en Australie. Et apparemment, en fait, les groupes qui sont en australie
sont les ancêtres...
Enfin l'ancêtre commun des marsupiaux australiens et aussi l'ancêtre finalement des marsupiaux australiens.
Non ! pardon. L'ancêtre commun des marsupiaux sud-américain est aussi l'ancêtre des marsupiaux australiens ce qui voudrait dire qu'il y aurait une dispersion
Euh...
Une dispersion peut-être à partir de l’Amérique du Sud. Mais ! mais, mais, mais, ce scénario est uniquement basée sur les marsupiaux moderne.
Rappelez-vous les marsupiaux avait une distribution mondiale
Donc peut-être que c'est en fait, les
marsupiaux qui étaient présent à travers le monde....
Et finalement, enfin bref.
Les marsupiaux étaient présent à travers le monde
à l'éocène, à l'oligocène... jusqu'au miocène.
Et en fait ceux qui ont survécu, peut-être que c'est juste un coup de bol, si euh...
Si finalement ils...
tous les basaux ont survécu que en Amérique du Sud et que tous les dérivés n'ont survécu qu'en Australie, mais bon.
C'est plus probable quand même que l'ancêtre commun de tous les marsupiaux australiens soit arrivé, enfin...
soit arrivé en une fois en fait et pas en plusieurs vagues. Du moins, c'est ce qu'indique la phylogénie des placen... des marsupiaux modernes.
Alors évidemment on ne peut pas parler de la diversité des marsupiaux sans parler de ce qui s'est passé en amérique du sud et notamment
en matière de carnivores. Et donc c'est le moment de parler sparassondontes
ou des Borhyaenidæ. Donc les Borhyaenidæ étant les plus connus des sparassondontes,
c'est à dire les mamif... les marsupiaux
Sud-américain carnivores. Le plus connu d'entre eux étant évidemment Thylacosmilus que vous voyez ici, le fameux...
kangourou à dents de sabre parce que je vois pas d'autre moyen de décrire cet animal qu'en disant que c'est...
encore pire c'est un koala dents de sabre, là c'est... là c'est vraiment choquant !
Mais en réalité il n'est pas directement apparentés ou kangourou ou au koala, c'est plus un opossum à dents de sabre qu'autre chose.
Donc, il se distingue du...
du félin à dents de sabre donc du placentaire à dents de sabre si vous préférez de, par plusieurs caractères :
déjà la taille du cerveau qui est très petite comparée à celle du félin. Donc ça c'est c'est plutôt un caractère de... de...
ben, comme je disais d'opossum. Les opossums ont un cerveau très petit comparé aux placentaires moyens donc voilà.
Ça se reflète chez le...
Thylacosmilus.
Les dents se prolonge très loin à l'intérieur du crâne,
comme vous pouvez voir les dents de sabre se prolongent très loin ce qui crée ces bosses en fait sur le dessus que le smilodon,
donc le dents de sabre placentaire n'a pas.
Et il y a ces espèces de fourreaux
sur la mandibule, pareil que le smilodon n'a pas. Mais on verra qu'il y a certains félins à dents de sabre qui en avait mais euh...
jamais aussi développés que chez le...
que chez le Thylacosmilus. Et le Thylacosmilus a typiquement un crâne de marsupial.
Un autre caractère aussi, oui c'est la, pardon, la barre postorbitaire que vous voyez ici.
Cette barque postorbitaire là, ce qui ferme l'orbite et qui donne à l'orbite cette forme bien ronde
est absente chez les félins à dents de sabre.
Alors d'une, vous pouvez voir ici,
sur l'arcade zygomatique de Thylacosmilus,
la suture entre le jugal et le squamosal, et vous pouvez voir que le jugal à une petite languette,
ici, qui se projette jusqu'à l'articulation
de la mâchoire. Et ceci est exactement comme l'opossum donc c'est un caractère typique de...
de métatheriens,
de marsupial, et vous pouvez compter aussi le nombre de molaires :
il y a une, deux, trois, quatre dents molaires,
et après vous avez une réduction du nombre de prémolaires parce que c'est un carnivore et que les carnivores n'ont pas
besoin de prémolaires. Mais vous voyez : une, deux, trois, quatre dents molaires bien distinctes comme
tout bon marsupial qui se respecte, chez  Thylacosmilus, donc le compte est bon on a bien tous les caractères d'un marsupial
chez ce bon Thylacosmilus, c'est donc un exemple flagrant de convergence évolutive
avec...
les mammifères euh...
Avec les félins à dents de sabre.
Alors il faut bien se représenter cette idée là, c'est que Thylacosmilus
est, n'est pas un félin à dents de sabre c'est vraiment un marsupial à dents de sabre.
Donc un opossum à dents de sabre et vous pouvez voir là, Thylacosmilus c'est une image...
elle est trop choupinou cette image !
Vous pouvez voir le petit Thylacosmilus dans la poche de sa mère ici, avec ses petites quenottes.
Alors ça c'est probablement faux, puisque je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure, la seule dent de lait que possèdent les marsupiaux c'est la quatrième prémolaire.
Donc...
Euh, pardon, c'est la troisième prémolaires. Bon je... c'est la dernière prémolaires quoi qu'il arrive !
Donc la seule dent de lait qu'on les marsupiaux c'est la dernière prémolaires.
Donc ils peuvent pas avoir des petites canines de lait comme ça les...
les bébés Thylacosmilus. Mais bref. C'est quand même trop choupinou et ça ça vous illustre quand même bien l'idée que,
voilà, faut pas...
faut pas se représenter Thylacosmilus du tout comme un mammifère placentaire.
Et un autre groupe qui...
qui à mon sens il ne faut pas négliger chez les... chez les marsupiaux, mais cette fois chez les marsupiaux australien,
donc on s'en va de l’Amérique du Sud.
C'est le groupe des diprotodontes.
Alors je sais bien qu'il y a d'autres groupes qu'il faut pas négliger chez les marsupiaux, notamment les Didelphimorphia.
Mais les Didelphimorphia, c'est vraiment les opossums, c'est les marsupiaux qu'on retrouve partout.
En tout cas pendant l'éocène et l'oligocène, ils sont absolument partout,
donc c'est le marsupial de base l'opossum, donc je vous en ai déjà parlé
rien qu'en parlant des marsupiaux de base, quoi.
Donc là on voit les groupes qui sont spécialisés, donc on a vu les carnivores spécialistes,
maintenant on va voir les herbivores spécialistes que sont les diprotodontes.
Donc les diprotodontes, ils sont fortement adaptés à un régime herbivores, et du coup ils ont des dents qui sont
lophodontes. Donc voilà, premier exemple de dents lophodontes avec les deux gros lovphe que vous voyez là
et des dents qui peuvent être donc bunolophodontes s'ils sont follivores ou
hypsolophodonte s'ils sont herbivores comme les kangourous (donc herbivores dans le sens graminivore).
Et les diprotodontes, et bien ils ont plusieurs caractères dérivés en plus de cette dentition bilophodonte,
ils ont des énormes incisives,
notamment les incisives du dessous, vous en avez euh...
une seule... donc vous n'avez qu'une seule paire
d'incisives au lieu de 4 incisives
sur les dents du bas, donc vous voyez, ça fait un peu comme des rongeurs,
et elles sont dites "procumbent" donc procumbent ça veut dire
proclive, inclinée vers l'avant.
Donc c'est un petit peu... c'est exactement ce que vous voyez là quoi. Les dents du dessous inclinées vers l'avant.
Donc ça fait un peu comme une pelle en fait, ils ont les incisives inférieures comme des pelles et ça fait pas mal ressembler
à d'ailleurs, à des rongeurs.
Et sur tous les diprotodontes, et notamment euh, c'est notamment visible chez les mégapodes que sont les kangourous,
les diprotodontes ont des pieds vachement bizarres.
Les diprotodontes donc, ont un pied extrêmement particulier, donc ce que vous pouvez voir ici, ils ont les doigts
2 et 3 qui sont très réduits le doigt numéro un est complètement absent.
Donc l'orteil un, si vous préférez le pouce de l'orteil,
est complètement perdu.
Le doigt 2 et 3, les orteils 2 et 3 sont réduits, et l'orteil tr... 4 et 5
finalement, ce sont les seuls orteils qui sont très développés. Donc ça se voit très bien ici, sur le pied du kangourou donc
là, les kangourous, finalement sautent sur le doigt 4 et 5, et principalement sur le doigt 4.
Mais ça se voit aussi par exemple chez un autre diprotodontes que, qu'est le koala. Donc si vous regardez le pied du koala,
vous avez les doigts 4 et 5 qui sont très développés et les doigts
2 et 3 qui sont fusionnés finalement, et pas deux doigts 1. Et c'est aussi le cas chez le wombat.
Enfin bref le koala, kangourou, wombat, ce sont les diprotodontes les plus typiques on va dire.
Mais vous avez évidemment
un registre fossile des diprotodontes qui est absolument formidable.
Les diprotodontes eux-même, tiennent leur nom de Diprotodon que vous voyez ici,
dont vous pouvez voir ici les incisives proclives,
promé... proéminentes sur la mâchoire et la morphologie bilophodonte
très typique des diprotodontes. Diprotodon  qui est ni plus ni moins qu'un wombat géant au final.
Et j'ai dit tout à l'heure que les diprotodontes étaient herbivores,
ce n'est pas toujours le cas : il y a eu un diprotodonte carnivore parce que, on est en Australie et donc ...
la niche des carnivores est vacante et elle est occupée aussi par les diprotodontes au pléistocène, du moins,
et au pléistocène, vous avez donc Thylacoleo,
que voici,
qui avaient des diprotodontes... alors il a perdu la...
il a perdu la morphologie bilophodontes parce que il a cet, il a ces espèces de dents carnivores en forme de lame, hein,
très typique des carnivores, mais par contre il a toujours la première paire d'incisives
du la mâchoire inférieure qui est proclive.
Donc la signature finalement des diprotodontes et de son, de ses ancêtres diprotodontes.
Alors Thylacoleo comme Diprotodon et de nombreuses autres espèces sont
très représentatifs de ce qu'on appelle la mégafaune australienne du pléistocène. Donc c'est une faune, c'est une mégafaune qui a finalement régné sur l’Australie,
et dans laquelle on trouve... ben comme je disais hein, Diproto...
Le Diprotodon, le Thylacoleo, des kangourous géant, on trouvait aussi des oiseaux géants euh...
proche du moa et ont trouvait Megalania, donc le...
l'équivalent du varan de Komodo, mais encore plus gros.
Des fois que vous vous demandiez si un varan de Komodo ce n'était pas déjà assez gros !
Et toute cette faune, ben finalement, toute cette mégafaune va disparaître à l'arrivée d'une espèces migrantes, cette espèce,
c'est l'homme ! c'est l'homme ! et alors là, là où il faut pas non plus faire
d'erreurs, c'est que c'est pas la colonisa... c'est pas de la colonisation dont je parle, ce n'est pas l'arrivée des européens, hein.
C'est l'arrivée des ancêtres des aborigènes.
Donc les ancêtres des aborigènes déjà, ont eu un tableau de chasse que vous pouvez voir ici qui est quand même assez euh
assez catastrophique hein ! Ils ont, ils ont quand même...
Leur arrivée a quand même foutu le bordel si je puis dire. Donc c'est pas...
c'est pas l'arrivée de... des colons britanniques dans les années 1800 dont je parle hein, c'est les ancêtres des natifs austra... australiens.
Donc voilà. Et dans le cas de l’Australie donc on sait qu'il y a eu aussi un changement climatique qui arrivait au même moment,
bon on le sait parce que déjà l'homme a pu arriver alors que, du moins à cette époque là, on pense
qu'il y a cinquante mille ans il n'était pas encore capable de construire des bateaux, donc ça veut dire qu'il y a forcément eu un...
une descente au niveau de la mer et donc, du coup un refroidissement.
Donc il y a quand même eu, il y a, il y a eu d'autres facteurs que l'arrivée de l'homme aussi qui ont joué et qui
alimente du coup un certain débat sur la responsabilité de l'homme dans cette extinction.
Ce qui nous amène aux placentaires, donc avec cette grande extinction de la mégafaune
australienne qui n'est finalement que le prémisse de l'extinction tout court des marsupiaux.
Nous arrivons aux mammifères placentaires le groupe, le plus diversifié
de mammifères modernes, diversifiés tant en termes du nombre d'espèces
puisqu'il y a beaucoup plus de mammifères placentaires que de marsupiaux ou de monotrèmes,
mais aussi diversifié en termes
d'écomorphologie, puisque nous l'avons dit tout à l'heure il y a des baleines
placentaires et il y a des éléphants placentaires et il y a des...
des...
chauves-souris placentaires que les marsupiaux n'ont pas.
Donc euh... donc une très grande diversité, une très grande diversité de taille aussi bref.
Et les placentaire vont connaître la même histoire que les marsupiaux mais en quatre fois. Donc ça on va le voir... on va le voir plus tard.
Ce qu'il y a d'important déjà à savoir à propos des placentairesc
c'est que le...
alors d'après le registre fossile,
les eutheriens apparaissent au jurassique, mais les placentaires n'apparaissent
que à la toute fin du crétacé, il y a à peu près 70 millions d'années, les premiers mammifères qu'on peut appeler des placentaires.
Donc il s'agit de Protungulatum et de Purgatorius,
respectivement
attribués, alors respectivement rattaché... Protungulatum, il pourrait être rattachée aux...
périssodactyles, c'est-à-dire aux chevaux,
et
Purgatorius pourrait être rattachée aux primates on en reparlera,
mais bref, voilà. Protungulatum et Protungulatum, ce sont les tout premiers
tout première espèce, enfin genre qu'on pourrait appeler placentaire et il se trouve
qu'ils apparaissent à la toute fin du crétacé. Donc ce qui veut dire que on a définitivement une origine
mésozoïque des placentaires, mais alors là où c'est fort,
c'est que d'après les phylogénie moléculaire, c'est à dire d'après les phylogénies basées sur l'ADN et les protéines,
et c'est ce que vous voyez là votre écran, bah en fait,
c'est pas seulement les placentaire qui apparaitraient au mésozoïque, mais bien tous les grands ordres de placentaires.
Donc ici, vous voyez de là toutes ses lignes qui connecte les espèces modernes il y en a beaucoup d'entre elles qui s'étendent, vous voyez
pfou ! jusqu'au crétacé ! voyez là, donc ça, là, ça voudrait dire que la lignée des écureuils par exemple "squirell" veut dire écureuils,
c'est voudrait dire que la lignée des écureuils là, elle s'étend jusqu'aux crétacé.
Là si vous prenez "armadillo" donc le tatou,
le tatou, il aurait aussi sa lignée qui s'étend jusqu'au crétacé on devrait trouver des tatous au crétacé, si on en suis cette phylogénie.
Si on suit cette phylogénie on devrait trouver des "aardvark" donc des oryctéropes au crétacé, on devrait trouver des éléphants quasiment jusque euh...
jusqu'au début du paléocène. Et ça pour autant qu'on sache, on en a pas.
Voilà. Et le seul cas où ça colle à peu près, c'est avec justement les primates. Donc si on suit la lignée des primates ici,
et qu'on remonte jusque là, là, effectivement on a du primate au crétacé. Mais...
donc on a Purgatorius qui est effectivement de la toute toute fin du crétacé,
70 millions d'années. Mais là, là, là si vous suivez cette ligne là ici où l'on devrait trouver des primates jusqu'à 80 millions d'années voire...
voire plus que ça, voyez là si on prend la toute base de cette branche, de la branche qui mène aux primates, on a presque
90 millions d'années donc.
Il y a de grosses incohérences en fait, entre le, ce que nous disent les phylogénies  moléculaires basées
sur l'horloge moléculaire, c'est à dire que, en comptant le nombre... finalement ce que font les généticiens avec l'horloge moléculaire, c'est qu'ils comptent
le nombre de mutations qui a eu lieu, qui ont eu lieu pendant la euh...
divergence des espèces,
et en modélisant finalement la... le temps qu'il faut entre chaque mutation,
il reconstitue la longueur de ses branches donc la longueur de chaque lignée qui les amène à une date.
Donc date qui est systématiquement donc,
si j'en parle, si j'en parle c'est parce que, c'est parce qu'on a passé le stade en fait où il s'agirait d'un
artefact de calcul. Il y a aussi ça, parce qu'évidemment, j'anticipe vos questions aussi !
C'est que...
Évidemment de la manière où je suis en train de l'expliquer, je l'expliquent d'une façon extrêmement simplifier le fonctionnement de l'horloge moléculaire.
Et du coup ce que vous êtes en train de vous dire c'est que, bah oui le temps, enfin je veux dire on peut pas
savoir combien de temps il y a entre deux mutations,
c'est un défaut de modélisation. Oui mais si j'en parle, c'est bel et bien parce qu'on a passé le stade où les erreurs de...
où les erreurs de modélisation en fait, sont la source du problème. On est arrivé à un stade où on finit par se demander :
soit il y a un gros truc qu'on comprend pas à propos des mutations de l’ADN,
et évidemment les généticiens vous diront que ce n'est pas le cas ;
soit
il y a un gros truc qu'on comprend pas au niveau du registre fossile et
s'il ya bien un truc qu'on sait à propos du registre fossile c'est qu'il est pas complet,
voilà.
Donc les généticiens
rejette la faute sur les paléontologues, les paléontologues rejette la faute sur les modèles utilisés par les généticiens, mais au final il y a un problème.
Il y a un problème quelque part et c'est certainement...
Le débat fait rage, mais c'est certainement une cause partagée. C'est à dire que oui les modèles peuvent être améliorés, mais oui va peut-être falloir...
envisager de..
d'étendre certaines de nos lignées dans le crétacé. On a des euthériens, on a beaucoup beaucoup de d'euthériens dans le crétacé,
notamment en Mongolie par exemple. La Mongolie est très connue évidemment pour ces Protoceratops et ces...
et ces Velociraptor, mais évidemment s'il y avait Protoceratops et Velociraptor, il y avait aussi d'autres animaux, y compris des des euthériens.
Donc il y avait des euthériens au crétacé, c'est pas le problème. Le problème c'est que, pour autant qu'on sache, ils ne sont pas rattachés aux placentaires.
Et la vérité c'est que, peut-être que si du coup.
Voilà ! Donc ce que ce que nous suggèrent les généticiens, c'est qu'en fait, ben... peut-être que si en fait.
Peut-être que ces euthériens ne sont pas seulement des euthériens, peut-être que ce sont des euthériens placentaires.
Mais voilà, c'était pour vous tenir au courant de ce débat. Il n'est pas fini, il est très loin d'être fini.
Bon bah, on attend les développements, les futurs développements.
Voilà. En tout cas, on a tellement beau registre fossile des
placentaires en fait, qu'on est capable de reconstituer un portrait robot de l'ancêtre commun.
Donc ce que je vous montre là c'est pas vraiment un fossile qui a été retrouvé, c'est juste le portrait robot de l'ancêtre en commun
qu'on peut reconstruire à partir de ce qu'on sait justement des euthériens du crétacé, des
placentaires du paléocène, et des inférences phylogénétique qui les relient, en fait.
Donc à partir de ça on peut dire que
l'ancêtre commun des placentaires, en fait, et ben ça faisait partie justement de ces animaux qui étaient pas très... qui sont pas, pas...
qui sont pas partis très loin du morphotype de base en fait des mammaliaformes. Donc vous rappelez de
Morganucodon,
petite musaraigne insectivores et nocturne. Bon bah là, on est typiquement là dessus.
On est sûr de la petite musaraigne insectivores et nocturne
pour l'ancêtre commun des placentaires. Donc un ancêtre commun finalement qui a pas beaucoup bougé de l'ancêtre commun des mammaliaformes. Donc euh...
Donc un animal qui ne fait que quelques grammes,
avec un cerveau relativement simple mais des os de l'oreille moyenne
complètement détachée de la mâchoire et qui forment déjà les trois ossicules hein, donc l'étrier, l'enclume et le marteau
(ou le marteau, l'enclume, l'étrier si vous préférez dans l'autre sens), le tympan évidemment ; et, et,
évidemment, mon caractère préféré : le pénis qui cette fois
(rire)
n'est pas bifide ou n'a pas quatre extrémités, mais le gland... il n'y a qu'un seul gland, voilà.
Donc, ça y est, le pénis à un gland !
Bravo les placentaires !
Et évidemment la dentition. Évidemment. Donc 1, 2, 3 molaires et une quatri... et une 4e
prémolaire, qui est... ressemble aux molaires mais n'est pas une molaire
Voilà. La différence entre molaires et prémolaires, c'est le nombre de racines.
Les prémolaires, les prémolaires ont primitivement une seule racines, ça peut évoluer chez les placentaire si, notamment chez les herbivores.
Mais primitivement les prémolaires ont une racine et les molaires ont deux racines, en fait.
Donc c'est ça la différence entre prémolaires et molaires. Donc si
vous avez une dent molariforme avec une seule racine, c'est une prémolaire molariforme.
Donc voila ! Voila et évident, et le nombre d'incisives aussi une, deux, trois incisives, contrairement aux
quatre incisives
inférieures chez les... chez les marsupiaux et 5 incisives supérieures
aussi chez les marsupiaux. Là vous avez trois incisives en haut, trois incisives en bas.
Nous y voilà donc chez les placentaires.
Donc comme je le disais, le plus banal des eutheriens c'est Juramaia, mais c'est pas le seul qu'on ait au
mésozoïque. On a aussi Eomaia qui était le plus connu, qui est probablement toujours le plus connu par rapport à Juramaia.
Mais bon, ils sont très similaires quoi, ce sont de petites musaraigne insectivores. Y a pas... Y a pas à tortiller.
Et maintenant, on va attaquer la phylogénie des mammifères. Alors là c'est le moment où
j'invite mes étudiants, et donc je vous invite vous aussi,
aller prendre un café, à respirer un grand coup,
aller prendre l'air,
faites une petite pause,
allez manger, allez faire quelque chose,  parce que là,
là, on va vraiment commencer à discuter. Là, ça va devenir sérieux ! Au cas... au cas où vous trouviez ça facile, jusqu'à présent évidemment.
Mais si vous trouviez ça facile et que ça commençait à devenir chiant pour vous,
Là c'est bon, il va falloir commencer à s'accrocher, là on commence à avoir du challenge, parce qu'on attaque la phylogénie des placentaires.
Et j'espère vous convaincre à l'issue de cette... de cette dernière partie de ce premier cours,
que ... sérieusement faut s'arrêter dessus !
Je veux dire c'est pas pour rien qu'on fait euh... qu'on fait tant de... enfin que c'est pas pour rien que je vais faire
sept cours sur les placentaire, et uniquement sur les placentaires,
et que j'ai seulement fait un quart de cours pour les marsupiaux. C'est parce que l'histoire des placentaires,
c'est vraiment, vraiment,
vraiment la galère !
(rire)
Et donc, donc voilà. Là, ce que je vous montre en fait, donc on est reparti ! voilà ! on s'y remet !
Donc là ce que je vous montre, c'est la phylogénie des mammifères telle qu'on la pensait...
encore dans les années 90 et au début des années 2000,
et telle que certains l'envisagent encore aujourd'hui, les vieux de la vieille, hein, l'envisage encore comme ça. Les... ceux qui ont de la bouteille.
Et puis ça, c'est la façon dont les gens qui suivent l'actualité
envisage désormais la phylogénie des mammifères.
Donc euh...
Et c'est la vision, finalement, qu'on apportée les généticiens,
l'évolution des mammifères.
Donc euh...
Alors
déjà, de ce point de vue là, dé...
déjà, dès maintenant, j'ai envie de dire... j'ai envie de dire que je suis pour cette phylogénie là,
pour la simple et bonne raison que encore une fois,
au début on avait quelques protéines, on... après on a eu que quelques gênes,
après on a eu plusieurs gènes, après on a eu des génomes entiers, et après on a eu des génomes entiers pour des milliers d'espèces.
et systématiquement, c'est cet arbre là qui revient, jamais celui là.
Donc, quand on regarde des génomes entiers sur des milliers d'espèces et qu'on retrouve toujours le même résultat
Et que ce résultat, c'est celui-là, ça veut dire que c'est ce résultat le bon.
Voilà. Donc même si au niveau de la morphologie,
c'est pas du tout la même chose qu'on retrouve.
Force est de constater que c'est les gênes qui gagnent et pas la morphologie. Donc,
cet arbre ne fait absolument aucun sens en terme de morphologie et vous allez le voir
au fur et à mesure des diapos que je vais vous montrer.
Mais c'est quand même celui là qui est le bon. Je veux dire faut arrêter de tergiverser sur qui qu'a raison qui qu'a tort, c'est...
C'est cet arbre là qui est le bon, point c'est tout. Et c'est la morphologie qui a tort. Donc avant, on avait un modèle
de phylogénie basée sur la morphologie, parce qu'on avait que ça, on n'avait pas les gènes.
Donc on avait les xénarthres à la base, donc les xénarthres c'est les, les
mammifères sud-américains. Et puis après, on avait une séparation qui était basé sur le régime alimentaire, donc vous aviez les insectivores,
vous aviez les rongeurs et les lagomorphes, donc des herbivores, vous aviez les...
les primates et autres espèces arboricoles et frugivores insectivores,
et puis vous aviez les animaux au...
dont le régime alimentaire est à base de protéines, donc les carnivores et les pholidotes. Les pholidotes c'est les pangolins donc c'est des... c'est des... fourmiliers.
Il y a certaines phylogénies qui groupaient les pholidotes avec les xénarthres parce qu'ils se ressemblent beaucoup,
il y a des... voila, vous pensez fourmilier vous pensez fourmilier sud-américain donc xénarthres.
Bon alors certaines fois, ils étaient avec les carnivores, certaines fois ils étaient avec les xénarthres mais voilà.
Mais ça faisait toujours sens au niveau de la morphologie hein, quoi qu'il arrive, c'est soit vous les mettiez avec les mangeurs de, de..
de protéines animales, soit vous les mettiez avec les autres trucs qui est qu'ils n'avaient pas de dents.
Euh et qui était ...
fourmilier.
Et vous aviez les
herbivores qu'on appelait les ongulés, voilà. donc herbivores, carnivores,
arboricoles,
petits herbivores,
Insectivores, et trucs sud-américains un peu barrés, voilà.
Et évidemment à la base les marsupiaux les monotrèmes,
qui ne sont pas des placentaires évidemment. C'est c'est pour enraciner la phylogénie.
Donc vous aviez une phylogénie qui niveau morphologie, bah,
faisait tout à fait sens et est tout à fait logique on va dire. Bon à part euh...
à par quelques petits points de détails par ci par là qui étaient débattus...
les pholidotes comme je le disais, les cétacés on les mettait pas toujours parmi les ongulés, mais bon voilà, il se baladait par là,
les tubulidentés c'est pareil, donc le
l'oryctérope c'est aussi un fourmilier, donc de temps en temps il partait du côté des xénarthres, mais voilà.
Globalement, on avait une image assez claire de la phylogénie mammifères et pouf ! d'un seul coup,
les généticiens nous disent que c'est pas ça du tout ! voilà !  Donc les insectivores complètement explosés,
les ongulés complètement explosés donc, mais bref, on va voir tout ça dans le détail,
et comme je le disais c'est la phylogénie des généticiens que je vais suivre parce que ils ont juste.
Quand on parle de génétique et de génomes complets, on parle de millions de paires de bases donc de millions de caractères.
La plus grosse phylogénie morphologiques qui ait jamais été faite, elle avait tout au plus quinze milles caractères.
Donc voilà ! On parle de millions de caractères contre, au maximum quinze mille caractères ! tu peux pas test.
C'est les généticiens qui ont raison. Et leur modèle...
on utilise encore, aussi la morphologie, donc le maximum de parcimonie
en cladistique
basée sur la morphologie.
Les généticiens maintenant, ils en sont à utiliser du bayésien, c'est des mod... des approches
probabilistiques, je veux dire, tu, tu peux pas test, tu peux pas test, la génétique voilà. Donc c'est les généticiens qui ont raison et...
Et finalement, on va voir que c'est pas, c'est pas si con que ça, en fait leur arbre, il est pas si con que ça.
Donc !
À l'intérieur des mammifères aujourd'hui on distingue trois super ordre :
Donc le super ordre en rouge,
le super ordre vert, le super ordre bleu, le super ordre jaune. Et le super ordre rouge s'appelle les Afrotheria
car il est composé de mammifères soit qui ne vivent qu'en Afrique,
soit qui ont un registre fossile qui pointent clairement vers l’Afrique comme étant leur centre d'origine.
Donc à l'intérieur de ces afrothères, on retrouve les Tenrecidæ. Donc lesTenrecidæ,  dont on retrouve
des représentants à Madagascar et en Afrique du sud. Ce sont des petit insectivore.
Les Chrysochloridæ, donc qui sont les taupes dorées du Kalahari et
uniquement du Kalahari, donc c'est là où je vous dis que c'est strictement africain. Donc ça veut dire que Les taupes dorées,
toute ressemblance qu'elle aient avec les taupes qu'on connaît en Europe,
sont, ne sont pas des taupes en fait ! C'est... Voilà, on appelle ça des taupes doré parce que ça ressemble à des taupes. Ce ne sont pas des taupes.
Ce truc est plus proche parent de l'éléphant qu'il ne l'est de la taupe !
Et c'est là que c'est beau ! c'est ça que c'est beau !
Donc les Chrysochloridæ, les Macroscelidæ, qu'on appelle aussi les rats à trompe qui ne sont pas des rats, mais qui
et dont la trompe n'est pas homologue à celle des éléphants,
c'est une convergence évolutive, ce qui est bien dommage parce que, effectivement les rats à trompe sont plus reliés aux éléphants qu'à
n'importe quelles autres espèces.
... euh de rats.
Les oryctérope
sont aussi des afrothériens, les Sirenia et les hyracoides.
Alors parmi euh...
Donc tous ces animaux, vous voyez ils ont des types écologiques extrêmement différents, je veux dire vous avez
basiquement ce qui est probablement l'un des plus petits mammifères du monde, donc les taupes dorées,
avec probablement, ce qui est le plus grand mammifère terrestre du monde, les proboscidiens.
Donc des animaux de plusieurs tonnes, des animaux de quelques grammes,
des insectivores, des... des fouisseurs,
des, donc ça c'est un fourmilier du coup, c'est... ça fait partie de ces animaux qui se nourrissent exclusivement de termites et de fourmis.
Vous avez des mammifères semi... des mammifères aquatiques, pardon, pas semi-aquatique, complètement aquatique, qui est qui plus est le seul mammifère
herbivore aquatique. Vous avez un truc qui ressemble à des rongeurs, vous avez un autre truc qui ressemblent à des petits rongeurs sauteurs, donc bref !
Bah c'est le merdier ! c'est le merdier ! Donc là
...et le registre fossile nous aide pas beaucoup de ce point de vue, de ce point de vue de comprendre d'où viennent tous ces animaux,
à quoi ressemblait l'ancêtre commun, finalement de tout ça. Parce que c'est ça la grosse question qu'on se pose.
Ça veut dire que tous ces types écologiques différents ont évolué à partir d'un ancêtre commun et là ce que vous voyez en gris en fait,
ce sont les groupes pour lesquels le registre fossile ne nous aide absolument pas.
Parce que le registre fossile, en fait, est pas assez complet et que quand ces animaux apparaissent pour la première fois dans le registre fossile,
il ressemble déjà aux espèces modernes dans les grandes lignes.
Dans le détail, évidemment ils sont un peu différents. Mais dans les grandes lignes, les premiers...
les premiers oryctéropes sont déjà des fourmiliers, les premières taupes dorés sont déjà des taupes,
enfin comme des taupes, les premiers Tenrecidæ sont déjà des insectivores, les premiers Macroscelidæ sont déjà des petites bestioles qui sautaient, donc voilà !
Donc il n'y a les proboscidiens, les Hyracoidæ et les siréniens qui ont vraiment subi des changements macro-évolutifs
conséquents, qu'on peut suivre à partir du registre fossile, ce qui veut pas dire qu'ils sont pas arrivés là
pour ces quatre groupes là, mais ça veut dire qu'on l'a pas... on les a pas bien documenté. Jusqu'à présent.
Et en fait, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? ben il se trouve que l'ancêtre commun, un
ancêtre commun des afrothères est arrivé en Afrique quelque part au crétacé,
ou bien tout simplement un groupe de mammifères a évolué et
s'est retrouvé isolé en Afrique au crétacé parce que l’Afrique au crétacé c'est séparé finalement du reste du monde.
Comme je le disais, il n'y avait pas de calottes polaires à l'époque, il faisait très chaud et donc le niveau des mers était très haut
et du coup, l’Afrique était vous voyez complètement séparées et de l’Eurasie et de l’Amérique du sud.
Alors il y a un ancêtre commun qui arrive et on sait pas trop d'où
- ou qui étaient déjà là - et comme il s'est retrouvé isolé en Afrique, ben il nous a fait une euh
il nous a fait une marsupial, si vous préférez
si vous voulez, il nous a fait exactement ce que les marsupiaux fait en Australie,
c'est à dire qu'il s'est mis à faire son petit job dans son coin, et il a évolué
dans tous les types écologiques possibles et imaginables
de l'herbivore géant, aux mammifères semi aquatique, aux petit insectivores, à la taupe et cetera. donc il s'est mis à tout faire,
tout seul, à part carnivores !
Voilà si vous remarquez les mammifères... les afrothères, le seul truc qu'ils ont pas fait ces carnivores. Le truc le plus carnivore que vous ayez c'est les...
Les...les oryctéropes.
Encore que dans le registre fossile, il y a du débat sur un groupe qui [s'amelle] qui s'appelle les Ptolemaiidæ qui aurait pu être
insectivores à un carnivore. Mais voilà. Don,c isolement de l’Afrique, au crétacé, et
l’Afrique qui est donc rester isolée pendant tout le...
toute la première moitié du cénozoïque jusqu'à l'oligocène, jusqu'à la fin de l'oligocène.
Donc au début du miocène, y a un petit pont de terre qui se forme avec l’Eurasie et c'est là que finalement
on va voir de nouveaux mammifères arriver, mais sinon les afrothères en fait,
ont évolué, se sont diversifiés et ont dominé l’Afrique pendant toute la première moitié du cénozoïque.
Et ça ça veut dire une chose importante et qui va peut-être euh, qui va peut-être vous surprendre, mais ça veut dire que, en gros
avant que là que l’Afrique soit connecté à l’Asie il n'y avait pas de zèbres, il n'y avait pas de lions,
il n'y avait pas d'antilopes, il y avait que ça !
Il y avait que ce que je vous affiche là, à l'écran
et leurs ancêtres évidemment. Et on va voir que, on va voir donc j'ai tout un...
il y a tout un cours sur les afrothères et plus particulièrement les pénongulés, c'est à dire l'ensemble proboscidiens,
siréniens, hyracoïdes, donc ceux qui ont un bon registre fossile.
J'ai toute une...
tout un cours sur les pénongulés pendant lesquelles on va voir que c'est, en fait, ces groupes là, et notamment les hyracoïdes,
qui ont rempli les rôles de zèbres et de...
de zèbres et d'antilopes,
pendant le...
la première moitié du cénozoïque.
Les xénarthres, bah les xénarthre c'est à peu près la même chose mais en Amérique du Sud, donc les Xenarthra qui signifie
euh...
"articulation bizarre". Donc les Xenarthra, pourquoi... pourquoi articulation bizarre ? parce qu'en fait, dans les vertèbres lombaires, ils ont
une double articulation. Donc ce qui veut dire qu'en fait au lieu d'avoir une seule paire d'articulation dans les vertèbres
au niveau des lombaires, en fait ils ont deux paires d'articulation et ça c'est très rare chez les mammifères.
C'est un caractère qu'on retrouve chez les serpents.
Donc la double paire d'articulations entre les vertèbres, mais c'est un caractère qu'on retrouve quasiment jamais chez les mammifères,
à part chez les xénarthres. Donc les xénarthres, ils doivent leur nom à cette double paire d'articulations dans les vertèbres
et ils ont d'autres caractères morphologiques très distinctifs qu'ils partagent tous, donc
contrairement aux afrothères, c'est un groupe qui, au niveau morphologique, est assez cohérent.
C'est... ils ont en plus de cette articulation ce qu'on appelle un synsacrum, c'est à dire qu'en fait le... le...
le bassin est complètement fusionné aux vertèbres auquelles il s'attache,
(donc qui s'appelle les vertèbl... les vertèbres sacré). Donc le bassin et les vertèbres sont complètement fusionnées
et forment un synsacrum donc c'est un seul os cohérent en fait, au lieu d'avoir le bassin un peu détaché en fait.
C'est un... C'est un os qu'on retrouve aussi chez les oiseaux.
Donc encore un caractère un peu reptilien j'ai envie de dire. Bon si vous considérez les oiseaux comme des reptiles.
Devrais-je dire des sauropsides ! voilà, pour les... pour les guérilleros de la cladistique.
Euh... mais voilà c'est encore un caractère de...
qui est très peu commun chez les mammifères le synsacrum.
Et ils ont aussi cette particularité, c'est d'avoir des dents soit toutes pourries soit pas de dents du tout.
Qu'est ce que je veux dire par tout pourri, c'est qu'ils n'ont jamais d'émail en fait aux dents,
et leurs dents ont une morphologie extrêmement simple, ils ont jamais de p... en fait, ils ont complètement perdu le plan tribosphénique.
Donc ils n'ont pas de dents tribosphéniques. Il y a toujours de l'occlusion entre les dents, vous pouvez voir que les dents,
elles ont toujours une occlusion les unes avec les autres, mais le...
la tribosphénie est complètement perdue et l'émail aussi, donc c'est des dents qui sont uniquement faite d'ivoire, de dentine.
Et donc parmi ces... parmi les xénarthres donc, c'est un groupe qui est déjà
cohérent morphologiquement et c'est pour ça qu'ils avaient déjà été reconnus dans les phylogénies morphologiques.
Donc ça, ça a pas trop changé.
Et c'est un groupe qui est aussi cohérent dans son origine "sudna..." sud-américaine et dans sa distribution toujours sud-américaine.
Donc on y retrouve
le groupe finalement des omnivores qui s'appelle les Cingulata qu'on peut tout simplement appeler les... les tatous,
le groupe des herbivores euh... arboricoles qu'on appelle les ...
paresseux et qui s'appelle les Folivora en termes scientifiques, et le groupe des insectivores donc des fourmiliers
c'est à dire les Vermilingua, Vermilingua qui évoque du coup la langue vermiforme
des euh.. des fourmiliers. donc les fourmiliers sont ceux qui ont complètement perdu les dents pour les raisons que j'ai déjà évoqué qu'on euh...
en relation avec le fait d'avaler, enfin d'avoir plein de terre dans la bouche et d'essayer de mastiquer la terre.
Et donc pareil même histoire heu...
quelque part au crétacé le...
l'ancêtre commun des xénarthre se retrouve isolé en Amérique du Sud qui
reste isolé non pas jusqu'à la fin du... non pas pendant la première moitié du cénozoïque mais pendant la quasi-totalité du cénozoïque.
Donc la connexion que vous voyez, l'isthme de Panama
que vous ne voyez pas ici encore apparaître en fait ne va se former qu'il y a deux millions d'années et on verra dans la...
dans le, le, le...
le cours que j'ai s... que j'ai préparé pour...
juste à propos de l’Amérique du Sud,
en fait ce qui s'est passé en Amérique du Sud pour que évoluent des trucs aussi bizarres que les xénarthres,
mais aussi des trucs aussi bizarre que Thylacosmilus parce que
faut reconnecter ça aussi avec ce qui s'est passé chez les marsupiaux, les marsupiaux aussi se sont retrouvées...
isolées en Amérique du Sud.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on a des trucs aussi bizarres que Thylacosmilus. Parce que il n'y avait pas de, de
carnivores classiques en Amérique du Sud. Les jaguars. Donc les... il n'y avait pas de jaguars, il n'y avait pas de
lama donc les herbivores non plus n'était pas là, il n'y avait pas de lama, il avait...
il y avait d'autres groupes d'herbivores, dont les paresseux, mais... et particulièrement les paresseux géants, mais on parlera de tout ça pendant l'épisode
sur l’Amérique du Sud.
Là, tout ce que je vais vous montrer, c'est que donc
on a un isolement qui se met en place au crétacé avec l'an...
probablement l'ancêtre commun des xénarthre qui se retrouve coincé là et qui se diversifie dans tous ces groupes écologiques
dont on a parlé : les herbivores, les...
les "anteaters" donc les... les fourmiliers et les omnivores.
Et le tout premier... les toutes premières traces qu'on a
de xénarthre, elles datent de la fin de l'éocène,
et il s'agit donc de ce petit crâne, ici qui ressemble beaucoup à celui d'un... d'un tatou moderne et de ces
ostéodermes qui ressemble aussi à ceux des tatous moderne.
Donc euh... donc, donc, donc, et ben on a très probablement déjà des tatous
dès la fin de l'éocène, donc ce qui encore une fois pointe du doigt une origine beaucoup plus ancienne de l'ancêtre commun
des xénarthres.
Le groupe en bleu maintenant. Le groupe en bleu ici,
en fait il est... il regroupe des... des membres de deux clades bien identifiables.  donc,
ce groupe en bleus s'appelle les Euarchontoglires.
Et ça c'est probablement mon nom préféré de tout ce cours les Euarchontoglires.
Donc pourquoi Euarchontoglires ? parce que ce groupe
regroupe... ce clade regroupe ce qu'on appelle les archontes et les Glires.
Donc les archontes, ce sont les...
ce sont les... c'est le petit groupe dans lequel on retrouve les primates, les dermoptères, les Scandentia, donc le groupe d arboricole.
Et alors, autrefois on plaçait les chiroptères parmi les archontes,
mais ce n'est pas du tout soutenu par les analyses génétiques donc j'ai mis chiroptères avec un
point d'interrogation mais en réalité, vous pouvez d'ores et déjà les oublier,
les analyses génétiques ne soutiennent pas du tout que les chiroptères fasse partie des archontes.
Mais disons que autrefois
les arch* les chiroptères étaient placés parmi les archontes, c'est ce qu'on pouvait voir dans le premier arbre que je vous ai montré.
à propos des placentaires. L'arbre morphologique.
Et vous avez les Glires donc, qui sont les petits herbivores.
Donc la partie arboricole du groupe
et la partie herbivores du groupe.
Donc la partie herbivore du groupe dans lequel vous retrouvez les ga*
lagomorphes que sont les lapins et les Rodentia, c'est à dire les rongeurs.
Donc les lagomorphes, les lapins, ne sont pas des rongeurs. Déjà première chose à retenir de ça,
les lapins sont bien séparés des rongeurs et appartiennent à leur propre ordre qui s'appelle les lagomorphes.
Déjà, première donnée très importante.
Deuxième donnée importante,
c'est que, en fait de tous ces groupes, il n'y a guère que les primates, les lagomorphes et les rongeurs qui ont un registre fossile
digne de ce nom. Les dermoptères et les Scandentia, alors vous avez probablement même jamais entendu parler des dermoptères et des Scandentia.
Les dermoptères, on les appelle aussi les colugo et les Scandentia on les appelle les toupayes.
Donc voilà ça vous avance hein ?
(rire)
Au moins vous savez quoi googler si jamais vous saviez pas ce qui était un dermoptère et un Scandentia.
On appelle aussi les... les dermoptères on les appelle aussi les lémuriens volant, des fois, mais bon c'est bof, voilà.
Les chiroptères ont un très bon registre fossile mais encore une fois
pas de... ce ne sont pas vraiment des Euarchontoglires, c'était autrefois considérés comme des euarchontes,
mais ce n'est plus le cas.
Donc, à l'intérieur des Euarchontoglires comme je vous l'ai dit, on a un beau registre fossile des primates qui remonte
jusqu'au crétacé avec Purgatorius que vous voyez ici apparaître à l'écran.
Donc Purgatorius, vous voyez en bas à droite, c'est l'os de la cheville de Purgatorius, c'est... c'était donc l'archétype encore une fois de...
du placentaire paléocène, mais il a déjà des caractères qui le relie aux ple* aux primates,
donc on détaillera tout ça dans la... le cours qui est spécialement dédié aux primates.
Ne vous en faites pas, mais voilà. Purgatorius, la seule chose à savoir (le) maintenant c'est que Purgatorius
est le plus ancien Euarchontoglires fossile qu'on ai et il vient d’Amérique du Nord
et il vien* il appartient d'ores et déjà à la branche archonte des Euarchontoglires
et on a aussi Paramys, qui lui, appartient à la branche
Glires des Euarchontoglires, c'est à dire du côté lagomorphes et rodante* et rongeur de la force.
Et Paramys vient du paléocène lui aussi d’Amérique du Nord donc, pour les Euarchontoglires,
on se dirigerait plutôt vers une origine nord-américaine et là vous commencez à sentir
le pattern qui se forme : le clade rouge c'est les espèces africaines, le clade vert
les xénarthre, c'est les espèces sud-américaines, le clade bleu c'est les espèces nord-américaines...
Là vous commencez à sentir qu'il y a un pattern qui se forme,
Y a... il y a quelque chose qui est en train de se produire euh...on...
on commence à attendre le dénouement de tout ça.
Et donc le dénouement de tout ça va venir avec les laurasiathères.
Donc Laurasiatheria, donc les animaux de Laurasie, littéralement.
Pourquoi ? parce qu'ils auraient une origine laurasienne.
Mais le problème c'est qu'on sait pas exactement si c'est Amérique du Nord ou en Asie,
très probablement Asie mais vous allez voir que le registre fossile est pas si clair que ça.
Mais bref
No spoiler pour l'instant, qu'est ce qu'on trouve chez les laurasiathères ? ben les laurasiathères donc c'est le groupe
qui est le plus diversifié non pas en nombre d'espèces mais, en termes de diversité écologique. donc
Donc euh... pourquoi je dis pas en nombre d'espèces ? parce que évidemment leuh... les..
les clades qui contiennent le plus d'espèces ce sont les rongeurs et les chiroptères.
Donc euh... Et le problème c'es* et dans* et c'est dans l'ordre :
d'abord les rongeurs et ensuite les chiroptères. Donc les rongeurs appartenant aux Euarchontoglires, il y a en fait plus d'espèces d'Euarchontoglires
simplement parce qu'il ya des rongeurs en fait.
Et après vous avez 300 espèces de primates ce qui n'est pas dégueulasse non plus, donc voilà, ça ça fait un bon clade.
Mais les laurasiathères, ils ont les chiroptères, il y a quand même quatre mille espèces et ils ont les cétartiodactyle qui ont...
qui ont un bon 300 espèces à leur actif aussi. Donc voilà !
C'est quasiment à égalité entre laurasiathères et les Euarchontoglires. La différence c'est que les laurasiathères sont très
diversifiés du point de vue écologique. Donc vous avez les mammifères volants que sont les chiroptères et dont la...
l'affinité laurasiathèrienne n'est plus à démontrer grâce, encore une fois la génétique, mais vous avez aussi les cétacés.
Donc les cétacés qui forment avec les artiodactyles le groupe des cétartiodactyles donc,
on verra pendant un cours totalement dédié aux cétartiodactyles comment ça se fait que, finalement
on associe les baleines avec des espèces terrestres comme les artiodactyles.
Et pourquoi, pourquoi celles-là plutôt que n'importe quelles autres au final hein ? parce que finalement,
les cétacés ont une origine terrestre mais pourquoi ce serait parmi les artiodactyles, c'est ce que nous verrons.
Et puis vous avez aussi d'autres herbivores comme les périssodactyles, donc les chevaux et les rhinocéros.
Dans les artiodactyles, vous avez tout ce qui est antilopes, vaches, ruminants etc. les cochons, les hippopotames.
Vous avez des fourmiliers comme le pholidote, vous avez des insectivores
qui s'appelle les Eulipotyphla, donc voilà plutôt que de les appeler "Insectivora" ils ont préféré les appeler "Eulipotyphla".
Merci les généticiens,
pour ce cadeau. Voilà. Non mais il faut savoir que le simple fait d'enlever les tenrec et les taupes dorée des insectivores,
[rire]
a poussé les généticiens à renommer le groupe des insectivores les Eulipotyphla. Avant, ça s'appelait les Insectivora.
Donc même si aujourd'hui il y a toujours QUE des insectivores parmi les Eulipotyphla, faut quand même les appeler Eulipotyphla.
Donc c'est pour ça que je dis merci !
...aux généticiens, mais bref.
Et vous avez bien sûr les carnivores donc,
niveau type écologique, ils sont plus diversifiés du coup que les afrothères, parce qu'il y a des volants et des carnivores voilà !
Et le registre fossile de ces Laurasiatheria
remonte jusqu'aux paléocène
avec la possibilité que Protungulatum soit...
reli* soit à relier avec les...
avec les Laurasiatheria, mais ça c'est pas évident, mais si Protungulatum est un Laurasiatheria,
ça voudrait dire qu'on aurait aussi du Laurasiatheria au crétacé.
Et Protungulatum vient d’Amérique du Nord.
Comme les Condylarthra, donc ce... comme ce condylarthre. Donc voici ce qu'on appelle un condylarthre, c'est un..
c'est un ongulé primitif on va dire,
mais ce condylarthre en particulier qui s'appelle Phenacodus en fait a ceci de particulier qu'il a
le doigt du milieu qui est plus gros que les autres, ce qui est un caractère typique
des périssodactyles donc des rhinocéros et des chevaux. Les chevaux n'ont même plus que le doigt du milieu en réalité.
Donc euh.. donc il se pourrait que Phenacodus soit en fait un proche parent des chevaux ce qui ferait de lui un des plus anciens euh...
un des plus anciens...
Laurasiatheria et vous avez Himalayacetus du paléocène d’Asie qui est aussi l'un des plus anciens Laurasiatheria.
Et là pour le coup, c'est un cétacé comme le dit le nom "Himalayacetus" donc vous pouvez voir que Himalayacetus ressemble beaucoup
si vous connaissez Pakicetus ou Ambulocetus, vous pouvez voir qu'il leur ressemble beaucoup,
c'est normal, c'est parce que il est à peu près du...
il est même un peu plus vieux que Pakicetus, mais il ressemble
davantage à Ambulocetus qu'à Pakicetus, mais ça c'est une autre histoire.
De toute façon, là, voilà. C'est le seul fossile qu'on a des Himalayacetus, donc là je vous donne ça, c'est juste pour vous
mettre l'eau à la bouche pour le cours sur les cétartiodactyle, et aussi pour vous encourager à aller voir le cours
sur les cétacés que j'avais déj* que j'avais fait il y a de cela 5 ans je crois.
Cours qui est toujours en ligne. Il est...
alors, je l'avais remis à jour il y a cinq ans mais bon depuis cinq ans il y a évidemment des choses qui sont ressorties, mais globalement,
il y a juste plus d'espèces d'odontocètes basales
qu'il y a cinq ans, parce qu'il y a des groupes qui se sont mis à beaucoup bossé
sur les cétacés mais voilà tout ce que j'y dis est toujours vrai.
Voilà. C'est juste que maintenant la diversité de certains groupes a changé, voilà les odontocètes basaux, euh...
les Xenorophidæ
voilà, notamment sont beaucoup plus diverses
maintenant qu'ils ne l'étaient il y a cinq ans.
Et l'origine des mysticètes aussi a été repoussée à... à...
à l’éocène supérieur. Ce qui n'était pas... ce qui de même, n'était pas encore le cas il y a cinq ans.
Mais voilà, c'est du détail quoi. Tout ce que j'ai dit, tout ce qui est morphologie par exemple, et écologie n'a pas changé et
risque pas de changer de sitôt. Donc voilà le cours est toujours en ligne,
je vous encourage à aller le voir, si l'évolution des cétacés vous intéresse, mais on en reparlera de toute façon
pour l'évolution des artiodactyles.
Donc voilà, là ce qu'on... c'est ce que je vous disais donc on a le...
possiblement les plus vieux fossiles et en Amérique du nord et en Asie, donc c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle les Laurasiatheria, c'est
parce qu'ils n'ont pas pu se décider en fait euh...
de quel continent de la Laurasie venez les Laurasiatheria, voilà. Mais il est fort probable qu'ils aient une origine asiatique,
Ce qui
ce qui du coup nous amène dir* je vais directement sauter à cette diapos là, ce qui du coup nous amène à cette diapos là,
où finalement vous avez une euh...
une... une...
une division des mammifères qui n'est pas tant écologique, c'est-à-dire rappelez vous la... la...
la morphologie, ce que nous disait la morphologie, c'est que vous aviez les herbivores, les insectivores, les arboricole et les petits euh...
et les petits herbivores qui étaient bien séparés. En fait cette division elle serait pas écologique mais en fait elle serait très fortement contrainte
par le... la dérive des continents. Donc vous avez les continents qui se séparent pendant le mésozoïque,
donc la Laurasie enfin, l’Europe et l’Asie qui se sépare de l’Amérique du Nord
pendant le jurassique, pendant la fin du jurassique et, l’Amérique du Sud et l’Afrique qui se séparent au crétacé et qui se séparent aussi de...
de la Laurasie* de la Laurasie. Donc la Pangée qui se disloque au final, c'est ni plus ni moins que ça.
Et bien, pendant la dislocation de cette Pangée et il y a les ancêtres
de chacun des groupes qui se sont retrouvées isolées sur chacun de ces blocs
conduisant donc à l'évolution
complètement convergente des mêmes types écologiques. Donc en Afrique vous allez avoir des grands herbivores
des espèces marines, des petits herbivores, des...
fourmiliers et des insectivores et en mê* et dans la moitié nord vous allez avoir des grands herbivores
des fourmiliers, des petits insectivores, des espèces marines,
et puis vous allez avoir des arboricoles et en Amérique du Sud, vous allez aussi avoir un autre euh... les mêmes types écologique, donc les... les...
les fourmiliers, les arboricole
euh... et puis on va voir tous les autres groupes qui se sont
diversifiés aussi en Amérique du Sud. Comme je vous l'ai dit, il y a les marsupiaux
qui ne sont pas des placentaires, donc qui ne sont pas représentés ici, mais évidemment les marsupiaux vont occuper la niche des carnivores. du nord.
Les...
et des groupes comme les méridiongulés, on va voir ont occupé les niches des herbivores. Donc voilà ça c'est...
donc l'histoire des placentaires en fait, si elle n'a aucun sens du point de vue morphologique, elle fait totalement sens du point de vue
euh...
biogéographique du point de vue de la... de la cassure finalement de la Pangée.
Et ça, c'est quand même vachement cool.
alors oui, je sais ce que vous allez me dire :
cette image est fausse parce que du coup ils ont mis les Euarchontoglires sur l'asie
et les Laurasiatheria sur l’Amérique du Nord alors que ça devrait être l'inverse.
Oui je sais. je sais, mais c'est quand même* ça reste quand même l'image la plus visuellement euh...
parlante que j'ai pu trouver sur le sujet, voilà. Je suis au courant, merci.
Après la...
l'une des grandes questions qui s'est posée, mais là je vais aller très vite là dessus, c'est en gros euh..
quel groupe est relié avec qui ? parce que là, je vous ai montré les quatre groupes : Afrotheria, Xenarthra, euh...
"Euarchontoglires" donc les Euarchontoglires et les Laurasiatheria, mais évidemment,
ça veut pas dire que ces groupes sont forcément dans cet ordre là. Alors on est à peu près sûr
que les Laurasiatheria et les Euarchontoglires forme un clade qu'on appelle
les Boreoeutheria, mais après il y a des petits doutes sur vous se mettent les xénarthres et les Afrotheria donc vous avez
deux hypothèses basiquement,
l'hypothèse où c'est les xénarthres les plus basaux, les Afrotheria qui sont groupe frère des Boreoeutheria,
hypothèse qui s'appelle donc les Epitheria ; et vous avez... euh...
l'hypothèse où il y a les Boreoeuthe* où les les Afrotheria son groupe frère des Xenarthra,
et qui s'appelle l'hypothèse Atlantogenata. Je présente pas l'hypothèse Exafroplacentalia parce que globalement
c'est une des moins soutenue on va dire.
Donc il y a encore des doutes à ce propos là, donc
les gén* les analyses génétiques sont pas toutes très très claires de ce point de vue là, il y a des... il y a des... contradictions.
Donc l'arbre que je vous montre depuis tout à l'heure soutient les Exafroplacentalia.
Depuis le début, c'est ça que je vous montre. Mais en réalité euh...
ben déjà
mais en réalité voilà il y a débat, il y a débat. Voilà, c'est tout.
Les Atlantogenata, il y a pas beaucoup de soutien du point de vue de la génétique mais,
il y a l'avantage que,
quand on regarde la distribution géographique en fait, ben on aurait un clade qui correspondrait à l'ancien Gondwana.
Et ça c'est cool. Comme on sait que le Gondwana s'est séparé du reste
euh...
Enfin quand on sait que les deux blocs du Gondwana ne se sont séparés au crétacé,
ça aurait du sens de placer les deux clades issus du Gondwana
dans le même clade en fait, et donc là les Atlantogenata feraient sens du point de vue géographique,
mais par contre ce qui fait sens du point de vue morphologique c'est les Epitheria.
Parce que, parce que quand on regarde finalement le euh...
quand on regarde la morphologie des afrothères et des Boreoeutheria, bah ils partagent un caractère qui est :
la réduction de la fibula
qui ne... qui donc ne tou* ne s'articulent plus avec le fémur donc.
Voici le tibia d'un...
Voici le tibia d'un
d'un tatou donc d'un xénarthre. Et voici sa fibula vous voyez que ça fibula s'étend jusqu'en haut du tibia
et donc s'articule ici avec le fémur, on voit bien la facette d'articulation du fémur. Par contre quand on regarde les autres euh...
les autres animaux, les autres mammifères bas on voit que la fibula est en fait un tout petit os réduit et que l'articulation avec le
fémur appartient au tibia. Et voilà, ça se voit, donc ça c'est un tarsier, ça c'est un lapin,
ça c'est un chimpanzé, à chaque fois vous voyez la fibula est toute petite, réduite et ne s'articulent finalement qu'avec euh...
et ne s'articulent qu'avec le le le tibia et que le tibia lui-même s'articule avec le fémur.
Donc voila. Voila le... toute l'histoire ! donc les Epitheria seraient soutenu par plus de données morphologiques et
plus de données génétiques en gros, donc on se dirigerait plutôt vers euh
un dénouement Epitheria de... du débat.
Alors en conclusion, en conclusion ben
pourquoi s'intéresser à ce point aux mammifères placentaires ? ben comme je le disais parce que déjà ils sont beaucoup plus
diversifiés, donc on va on va passer dias* directement à cette diapos là.
Voilà ils sont beaucoup plus diversifiés.
vous pouvez voir ici donc le, le, le
le compte des espèces.
Ouais j'ai dit... alors tout à l'heure j'ai dit il y a 5 000 espèces de rongeurs. Non ! il n'y a pas 5 000 espèces de rongeurs, autant pour moi,
il y a 1 500 espèces de rongeurs, il y avait une histoire de 5, mais ce n'était pas le bon autant pour moi.
je fais des bêtises. Je dis des bêtises !
donc il y a 1 500 espèces de rongeurs mea culpa
il y a 1 240 espèces de chauves-souris et donc vous pouvez voir les, les, les
les marsupiaux, ils sont là ! Voilà les marsupiaux c'est 6 % de la diversité,
donc même pas 300 espèces en gros, ça veut dire qu'il y a moins de marsupiaux qu'il n'y a de primates.
Je sais pas si vous considérez les primates comme un groupe extrêmement diversifié, mais si c'est le cas...
Mais si c'est pas le cas, ben voilà les marsupiaux sont encore moins diversifiés que les primates et pourtant il s'agit d'un
groupe qui du point de vue taxonomique, est censé être
comparable au placentaire donc la diversité des mammifères modernes est largement dominée
Par celle, par
par les placentaires
et ça, ça à plusieurs implications donc déjà bas vu qu'il y a beaucoup de mammifères placentaires
et comme il se fossilise très bien et comme les espèces peuvent être
différenciées rien que sur la base de la morphologie dentaire, bah on peut tracer des...
l'évolution de ces placentaires à travers le temps et à travers la stratigraphie comme ici, dans le paléocène d’Amérique du Nord
de façon extrêmement précise.
Et ça permet de voir, par exemple, des lignées évolutives
sans avoir même affaire de cladistique. Donc vous imaginez là, on a juste la mesure de la... de la molaire
donc c'est la longueur fois la largeur de la molaire, et juste en* en faisant un diagramme de la longueur x largeur de la molaire
dans une série
de fossiles ramassés sur cette colonne stratigraphique du paléocène, on arrive à voir
la divergence de lignée.
Voyez, 2 lignées, pouf 3 lignées, pouf 4 lignées et pouf 5 lignées.
Et ça, et ça je trouve ça assez
formidable ça veut dire qu'on peut voir la spéciation en temps réel avec les placentaire et ça, ça troue le cul ! voilà !
Je suis désolé, il faut dire les choses comme elles sont, ça troue le cul !
[rire]
euh...
on peut voir la spéciation en direct avec des placentaires,
et et on n'a même pas besoin* Là, là, c'est même pas une analyse phéné... phénétique, ça s'appelle une analyse stratos*
ça s'appelle une analyse, pardon je répète, stratophénétique,
donc c'est
c'est vraiment euh... la base vraiment c'est juste un caractère
et on met ça sur la colonne strati et boum ça fait des Chocapics, c'est juste absolument formidable !
Alors évidemment du coup au niveau de la stratigraphie, on va avoir des grandes tendances et la grande tendance est évidemment
la séparation du cénozoïque en deux parties le paléoz*
le paléogène
et le néogène, et en fait cette séparation du cénozoïque en deux parties paléogène et néogène, ben c'est finalement la séparation entre
la dominance de groupes archaïques
de...
de placentaires et la dominance des groupes modernes de placentaires.
Donc les groupes archaïques, ben vous avez les condylarthres, vous avez les Plesiadapiforme,
les Metatheria donc les marsupiaux qui était répandue de par le monde mais finalement vont finir réduit à l’Australie à la...
et à la...
à là...
l’Amérique du Sud, vous avez les multituberculés qui est un groupe venant directement du mésozoïque,
qui ne sont même pas des Mammalia au sens strict,
en tout cas pas d* pas d'après tout le monde, mais qui sont des mammaliaformes en tout cas
des mammaliaformes du mésozoïque qui survivent pendant la première moitié du paléo*
du cénozoïque donc pendant le paléogène et pouf finissent par s'éteindre
à la moitié voilà ! pouf du paléo*, du, du cénozoïque
donc voilà c'est cette séparation
des groupes taxonomiques en...
entre euh... qui définit finalement cette tranche de temps en fait. On va voir que cette tranche de temps, ce...
cette séparation entre le néogènes et le paléogène, on la retrouve dans plein d'événements
euh...
Plein plein d'événements euh... de, de la vie des mammifères donc. Ça va être, ça aussi,
ça coïncide aussi avec la première glaciation, la grande glaciation de la fin de l'oligocène, enfin de l'oligocène en général,
ça coïncide aussi avec euh...
avec les cétacés qui commence à devenir un groupe dominant
dans les mers, ça coïncide aussi avec la rupture de la... de l'isolement de l’Afrique, ça coïncide avec la... les...
l'herbe qui se répand à travers le monde, les "grassland", donc les savanes et les steppes qui se répandent à travers le monde. Donc bref,
c'est... il y a un gros* il y a une grosse crise et que je... et je suis même très surpris d'ailleurs que cette crise soit pas
considérée comme étant une crise d'exts* d'extinction de masse, au même titre que la crise de la fin du paléogène parce que c'est...
il y a vraiment du gros* du gros événement qui se passe entre le paléogène est néogène.
Donc voilà, un autre exemple de comment la, les, les,
les mammifères sont utilisés en biostratigraphie, donc vous avez la colonne
stratigraphique vous avez les étages et ici vous avez la division basée sur les mammifères, donc MN ça veut dire "Mammalian Neogene Stage".
Donc voilà on utilise des faunes de mammifères pour dater et finalement vous voyez que c'est datation sont presque plus pet*, enfin ces tranches
biostratigraphiques sont plus petites que les étages
que vous pouvez voir au dessus, donc on peut faire des tranches stratigraphique beaucoup plus fine grâce aux faunes de mammifères que
grâce à la lithologie ou à quoi que ce soit d'autre, donc ça c'est quand même assez formidable.
On peut étudier les extinctions bien entendu,
je vais pas m'étaler là-dessus, on peut étudier les paléoenvironnements et ça on le verra avec les ongulés les herbivores ro*,
et notamment la hauteur des dents des herbivores va directement être un reflet du paléo environnement donc la transition
depuis des milieux fermés de fo* et forestier jusqu'à des milieux ouverts donc de savane.
Et un exemple voilà, exemple de transition depuis milieu forestier jusqu'à milieu de savane
l’Afrique bien entendu, qui était complètement couverte de forêts
Euh...
Donc ça c'est l'éocène*, c'est le miocène inférieur
et qui depuis le miocène inférieur en fait,
bah devient de plus en plus aride donc commençant par le sud puisque le sud
est plus proche de l'antarctique donc forcément,
est moins sujet aux précipitations et puis voilà ça va se réduire, ça va se réduire
jusqu'au point où
voilà on va finir avec euh...
avec le climat moderne quoi
Donc voilà, c'est l'aventure que je vous propose de suivre pendant tout cet été : l'évolution des mammifères donc
je vous retrouve la semaine prochaine,
avec l'évolution des artiodactyles et des périssodactyles, donc l'évolution des ancêtres de, des chevaux, des rhinocéros,
des vaches, des cochons, des hippopotames, et des cétacés.
Voilà à la semaine prochaine ! ciao !